two
what's up what's up what's up what's up
[Music]
[Music]
grumpy grumpy grumpy
i just made a grumpy before the show
you don't say
i actually didn't i just said that to be
funny oh didn't poop today
just to be clear
thank you guys everybody for joining us
today off the rails it's may 11th boy
time flies doesn't it guys indeed
today's episode is sponsored by curology
and mint mobile thank you
we love you
boy have we got an action-packed episode
today
uh
talking about
the whole brendan the whole brendan shop
thing
just uh has exploded
and i feel like i'm included in this
drama now a little bit
don't you think so
well i've i uh i've had two friends now
that aren't regular listeners of this
podcast but um
are plugged into that whole comedy scene
reach out to me and be like what's going
on like are you involved in some drama
with brendan schwab what's happening
ah so i just want to touch on that a
little bit
because brendan went on uh bobby's and
kalila's podcast and uh
i want to
comment on that
um
and
even more interestingly as well at 2 30
one of these girls who's been on fresh
and fit you know how they have these
panels of girls where they basically
just berate them and tell them they're
second-class citizens
well one of them
uh
is calling in to the show
yeah so record scratch moment that's
right
uh and she has a lot to share
about you know
about the experience
so that'll be interesting
anyway uh how's everybody doing
it's wednesday my dudes
um this thursday that's tomorrow
uh new teddy fresh is coming out
this hoodie that i'm wearing
that i designed is coming out tomorrow
teddyfish.com
along with a bunch of other really cool
stuff this hoodie for women
this shirt by the way which i'm wearing
under the hood it says two petty to live
too pretty to die who can relate
right
uh
this is one of iowa's drawings staying
home tonight
can relate to that
one uh it's the same hoodie over and
over this
this one
i guess this is a restock sure it's been
out
this one
uh it's just showing the same pieces oh
this one's getting restocked cameron's
wearing it actually cameron show it off
gone but not forgotten
smiling down upon you
it's a big restock what's up cam i said
this could be you right here we're in
this
and i i believe that is a
i believe that is a
a triceratops on the right and a
stegosaurus on the left i'm brushed up
on my dinosaur trivia theodore is a
basically a
paleontologist he is a dinosaur expert
so what's his favorite
i think his favorite is the ankylosaurus
although he really he's really
interested about the argentinosaurus did
you guys know the brontest
bronchiosaurus when we were kids was
thought to be the biggest dinosaur but
since then they found one called the
argentinosaurus which is actually way
bigger the biggest dinosaur that ever
lived
argentinosaurus wow did you know that
uh i can't say that i did now you do
big deal
oh then there's this one i'm completely
alone i love that one so nice oh and
then this is a necklace i believe
handcuff necklace there you go
and uh fresh or covertate if you're
watching
these are
not life-sized
so
thank you
thank you
they love me they really love me what
can i say
[Applause]
okay so also
regarding abs fight
the whole event that's happening this
saturday what time does it start at
three we said
uh yes three pacific so we've been
talking about what are we going to do we
want to watch the fight we're not sure
how
so we've decided
that this saturday
at 3 p.m
for members only to treat our beautiful
wonderful members
we will be doing a members only live
stream
at
3
p.m
live streaming the whole event
you don't have to pay them just come
into our members only chat
and uh you can watch it
you pay us instead of them that is not
oh that's not what we're doing this is
not the plan
we will not be showing it but we'll be
doing a a react stream uh so to speak so
you'll have to uh you have to get a
pay-per-view yourself and you can pull
it up but then you can have us in
another uh window for a little watch
party
i thought they would get it for free
do you want another lawsuit sorry are
you fishing for that
i don't think i'd have much grand to
stand on broadcasting the whole event
and basically saying publicly just pay
me instead of that
that won't work well yeah i don't think
they'll fly okay so
apparently dan
says that you have to pay for it
yourself and you can just watch us
reacting to it yeah i'll be the bad guy
but um sorry i'm super excited man it's
gonna be fun we're just gonna be kicking
back some beers having some pizza is
everyone gonna be able to make it this
saturday
uh i will definitely be there uh cam i
wouldn't miss it sam are you going to be
there
hell yeah brother hell yeah brother
we're going to watch our boy
what's his name hussein or no what's it
what's that
that boy about to eat dirt's name
you talking about abdullah i know abe's
opponent oh bret
brett yes honda yeah honda well okay
that honda character about to get
about to
eat dirt
ian zach everyone's coming i will be
there wow
i think ela's even coming guys
so it's going to be fun
and uh love are you going to be
you're going to be on loan be joining
yeah so there you go the whole gang the
whole gang will you uh spring for the
ubers for us to get here since we're all
getting drunk
i will absolutely pay for everybody's
uber
if i ask you on the show
well come on you know i'd say yes i know
i'm just kidding let's be like that
you know i would do that
but uh too much wine sorry
none of those excels all right you guys
um you guys are getting that broke uber
black yeah you guys take that plebeian
whatever
uber [ __ ] uberpool
yeah uberpools only
they still do that the pool yeah no they
they stopped i heard they
stopped yeah
yeah that makes sense that makes sense
uber they're like you can save three
bucks and take an hour detour
me and eli did that once a while ago we
did the pool they picked up two people
and it took us so damn long to get home
tell you what but okay it's a nice
option
right why not yeah
um
there was a
uh the possibility of having um
a b
call in on zoom for a minute to check in
uh i had it later in the show but since
we're on the topic i know he's available
yeah bring him on let's just when we're
talking about it
yeah
before we get before we launch into
these big
topics i think we're gonna get stun
locked into yeah talking about these
things for a while the brendan thing and
the freshman fit thing by the way lots
and lots of support for a b on the
subreddit this one had almost 3 000
views
uh good luck av you're gonna kill it
what do you think about how you look in
that one
i'm into it to be honest yeah
i like stout you know low center of
gravity
i like what i'm seeing
you relate to the to the dwarves and
lord of the rings
you like their kind of their whole vibe
you mean the hobbit what no the dwarves
oh the dwarf more dwarfish more stout
exactly the doors were very powerful i
mean gimli could swing that axe
he was knocking fools up with one hit
you know kimly is the goat
so yes i think i look very good thank
you
and then of course just want to wish abe
good luck on his fight room for your
buddy
2 000 points
it looks like eminem in that picture
okay this one
now you're starting to look like golem
oh wait what happened a b turned into
eminem
wait what happened
and his fist got super big it looks like
he's got a hulk fist on
not even notice those details oh no look
at his fist look at his hand it's so big
damn so jealous look how big his hand is
it's like the size of my whole body
yeah this one
i can't say that i'm loving it
okay
this one
let's go a b
you know
i mean this is just getting ridiculous
now guys come on
it's impossible to be that size you
can't even exist at that size
like this one maybe i can see it with
some
like the shortest man in the world or
whatever it's probably something around
that size you know yeah
but that but you couldn't live at this
site i'm not even the smallest knee this
is ridiculous being sizes right now
chill
of course
this one i'm the size of an atom more
like a cell are just a single cell
organism on the carpet
thank you microscopic king and then of
course molecular king
i'm just an atom of some
parts
i'm just uh a molecular
uh piece of
of uh
yeah
it's getting pretty deep here guys
and
well why you guys look so red
are burned
what happened
uh
we underestimated the sun the florida
sun is no no joke man
it's no joke man you guys didn't put on
sunscreen
no we didn't oh come on lina yeah you
know better than that
i expect that a baby but
we know for next time though yeah for
next time we just went and bought some
actually
yeah
how long were you guys in the sun
actually
it was 30 minutes but check this out
does it hurt
you see yeah i see it yeah i know it
doesn't hurt but it's it's interesting
i'm curious to see if i get punched if
they'll be doing that
oh yeah are you worried that it's going
to be affecting your performance
not performance but i'm just going to
look like a tomato
i mean i don't know you it might be gone
by the time saturday it comes around
stay out of the sun though for christ's
sake until then
we'll see hopefully
how you guys doing what do you mean
we'll see
i mean we still have to go outside
it's it's hard to avoid
but we'll wear sunscreen but were you
were you sunbathing or just walking
around
i went to the pool yeah oh
the pool
all right how you feeling ab
i'm good i'm ready to get this over with
i'm super excited to just uh
have this in the past not be stressing
about it while i'm at work and
everything and just um hopefully once it
goes smoothly
what's the vibe there like
so uh
i thought idoves and all the other
creators are already at this hotel
they're not coming here until tomorrow
they're on a completely they're like 40
minutes away
uh wait why you're the one there
you're the only one there
i'm at this hotel right now yeah so i've
been driving 40 minutes to go train with
them every day so so they
so let me get this straight they put you
in some hotel like way the [ __ ] out of
the way and everyone else is in a normal
hotel
no no so they reserved us all in this
hotel that we're at now but that doesn't
start until tomorrow anyone who was
coming early to train they went out
there that's my fault for not checking
with ian
uh but yeah they found some small gym
out there so they're staying close to
that
i see
yeah
so you're out there by your lonesome
self
yeah well my brother came last night my
brother and my cousin and one of my
friends so
lina what are you what are you thinking
lina is he ready for all this
yeah ready and like you said just ready
to get it over with
yeah
yeah it's been very time consuming
i wish wally could be here um my coach
but you know michael idab's coach has
been really nice and been training me
the past couple days so that's good
are you ready to kind of tag in if you
need to lina
if it goes sideways
i could i think i could yeah yeah
yeah
there you go watch out uh
you're forgetting his name hondor watch
out dude
i'm excited to show everyone the uh the
teddy fresh gear i got for the fight
it's so nice oh okay it did look really
good but the pants were too long did you
guys get that sorted yeah we got it we
got them sized oh good good good good
yeah i saw a picture they look awesome
hopefully you're the best looking
outfit out there eh
oh for sure
you did it i mean
i mean be embarrassing if someone else
came out there and outshined us
i doubt it
yeah no it looks amazing
all right
are you drinking lots of water
lots of water yeah i'm staying hydrated
you getting lots of sleep
i am i've been sleeping really good out
here actually for some reason
is he what's he not doing lena what what
does he need to be doing better
he's been sticking to schedule honestly
i'll tell you i'll tell you what
so there's some misunderstanding that
because me and honda aren't having
professional fight that we don't have to
be in a certain weight range
and i just found out that's wrong we do
have to be within 10 pounds
so we were freaking out yeah and like
i've been slamming fast food and crazy
my god yeah i've been eating like [ __ ]
so that so are you gaining weight like
have you gained weight since you've been
there
yeah i've gained three pounds there you
go welcome to my world
[Laughter]
pound today
oh man
is that gonna slow you down though that
doesn't seem like a good way to train
your body
i know but i don't have much choices now
is he trying to lose weight is he trying
to meet you in the middle
yeah yeah yeah he's yeah he's
he's got to be like off water and [ __ ]
you know
as a raring now he's 190 and i'm 180. so
we're perfect right now so but just
because it's so hot here and everyone's
sweating he's still going to try to lose
a couple pounds and i'm just going to
try to gain yeah because on the day of i
mean you can fluctuate a pound or two
you know yeah so yeah
all right yeah
well we'll be watching on saturday i
don't know if you saw if you've been
watching the show
i did i did it or if you're also part of
the show still right i mean i don't know
you see what we talk about yeah
well i appreciate it and i hope i can
put on the show for you guys
a good show
bring home the dub don't embarrass us
all right
get knocked down that teddy fresh gear
i'm gonna take that back better
you know be good at actually if that's
like a meme if i'm just mean to
everywhere it could be like the yamcha
you could be like the dude wipe meme
remember that when uh
tyrone got knocked out and everyone just
saw that anyway all right you guys be
good keep going okay
thank you guys thank you all right we
need to appreciate it
any predictions for the fight
i
no no predictions we'll see how it goes
all right it's going to be fun
all right go and
can you punch him in the dick or no
allowed
i don't think so i think it's illegal
all right i just spit bond i was just
trying to help you out with ideas
all right guys
we'll be watching all right you guys
have a good time take care have fun
don't worry ab you know get in there
there's only a small chance that uh
you'll get brain damage or anything like
that
as long as i still have a job
by the way yeah yeah i mean well if
you're in a vegetative state i don't
know how i don't know how much some
sense that will make for me personally
but
i'm pretty sure we'll have some kind of
i mean we'll we'll take care of lena and
uh i'm sure there'll be some kind of uh
workers comp for you if you get like you
know well if it happens in florida
oh because that yeah if it happened in
florida we might have a we might need to
uh take that one this is horrible
we might need to take that to
arbitration
baby's gonna kill him by the way abe in
the florida sun you know they say
they've got ripe uh
beautiful tomatoes in uh florida and
i don't know if can they see that
i could i just saw it
he's turning he's turning into me man
with my red you look good as a tomato
actually so keep you know maybe a little
more sun
all right guys have a good show all
right bye guys have fun we'll be
watching good luck we're rooting for you
god bless
you all right bye guys
my brother
yeah he's
that's kind of a rough situation with
the dieting and the
you know
the sun
yes
did they not know i mean
sunscreen right
caught him off guard i don't know it is
kind of into the sun there is nuts dude
but okay there you go i'm super excited
for saturday
good knock them dead
all right well
um
a couple more things at the top of the
show
one being it's been the one year
anniversary as curtis
connor pointed out of the greatest tweet
of all time
of course ninja
ninja's uh iconic
i am in the middle of carrying a league
of legend game about to close it out and
my braless wife brings me a sandwich not
asked for
with chips as they get a double kill bot
lane
so how is your day going
not as good as yours buddy
wow
you know and i think conor uh curtis
connor did a really good public service
pointing this out and he saved it on his
you know
on his calendar he said
and i think that's really smart because
i mean
i wish ela didn't wear a bra around
by the way what is braless wife meant to
even
signify
yo i could see my wife's boobs through
her shirt dude see some tails epic
titties
my braless wife what is that what's the
what are we doing here
she brought me a sandwich i didn't even
ask for
i didn't have to that's the point so
when when love was in town dan reminded
us of this tweet and that never left my
mind so like whenever ninja or love
calls him nina is up on stream would
just be like oh it's braless blevins oh
yeah
shout out to nina bro
it's kind of serendipitous because right
now in the fortnight store you can buy
his uh ninja skin oh yeah shout out it
must it must be in honor of that tweet
yeah wait he got his skin and el nino
yeah el nino el nino
that's kind of cool for him
can you see his nips through his shirt
no they should bring that on though now
that skin comes out tomorrow i think
it so really is kind of to celebrate the
anniversary of this tweet
yeah
well there you go shout out to ninja
who's living his absolute best wife
oh this is it
i mean to be fair he did a lot for that
uh game so
he earned it he definitely earned that
will you be using the um
the ninja skin love
fortnite no i spent all my v bucks on
some anime skin yesterday so no they
don't have anything
left so yeah what enemy skin did you buy
i don't know some kind of a bundle i
don't know but really
just
i don't know i don't know what to expect
how to explain it it seems uh important
for you to have that skin maybe you
could ask your mom for a credit card for
some more v bucks
well as i said like i used my monthly
allowance on
v-bucks already oh that was okay i got
it yeah well that's a bummer man you
told us about how your dad slept through
the fish smell i'm just saying if he'll
sleep through that he'll definitely
sleep through you going through his
wallet and getting his credit for it
just saying uh yeah i'll reconsider i
guess yeah
and i get you need that skin at all
costs
[Music]
oh
where's my skin coming
right you have to become a fortnite god
first
also just just funny serendipitous thing
we were talking about andy dick
and we were talking about having him
calling to the show
and we were talking about how he's
rolling with like ice poseidon and all
those gangs
uh he just got arrested shout out to our
boy andy dick
give it up
just arrested on live stream wait it
happened on live stream yeah i couldn't
find the clip though they had a clip in
this article but it's it's unrelated it
was from like another incident like a
week prior or something so um removed
and cert wait they didn't have it on tmz
they did not
they referenced i guess nobody watches
his live stream if it's not clipped it
wasn't on live stream fails or anything
uh
i think that they're probably banned
from livestream failed to be honest oh
wow okay
well shout out andy dick you know we
were talking about what a piece of [ __ ]
he is
and only one week later the man got
arrested on stream for felony
uh estual
uh battery
yes round of applause soft clap
[Applause]
boy this guy is [ __ ] rock bottom he's
got a stream with ice poseidon
and he's too much of a jed jenner even
for that crew he's just getting arrested
man
yeah what a guy what a guy wait there's
a clip here wait that's what i said
that's a different clip i thought it
would be the one is this interesting or
no not really yeah
the video is pretty boring i just sent
it to you
oh the actual the the arrest video
yeah it's from outside and it's like
really far away okay
let's see it
what's he doing in a trailer that's not
his house is it that's where they like
they do like rv streams uh it's all the
cx like yo he's traveling in an rv with
them
yeah yeah how old is he in the 50s
easily maybe holy [ __ ] you guys
the most nasty disgusting like both of
them
comes out of that rv he's on the better
side of 60 traveling an rv with ice
beside and bro
whoa
oh dude whoa whoa whoa this is
real interesting man
what did he sell someone at the campsite
i mean what how did they even how did
the police even get him if he's doing
like a cross-country thing
well they do live streams outside out of
that rv all the time and they get like
raided and swatted every week
what a piece of [ __ ]
i made that that actually i got that was
interesting actually i gladly watched
that
holy smokes
i think my my last interaction with him
was like
ask him what he wants to talk about if
he were to call in
and he didn't
he didn't know who you were
well there was that theory that he was
talking [ __ ] that was just somebody
trying to yeah
okay good so we
debunked the original
but it was just so odd like
that whole interaction was just so out
there but we i think the whole thing
started from uh
we got trolled basically right
you should text him see if he's okay
i'd rather not
use his one prison phone call to call
into the show you know i extend that i
extend that invitation to andy you
i will accept the payment on that call i
will i will pay for it if you want to
use your call to call us collect
from prison
[Laughter]
someone donated for me to buy the
fortnite skin so i'm buying it right now
wait how much is it
it's probably like four bucks so i gotta
give you four bucks now
yeah how much do they give for you
guys
i hate i love i mean look it's nice
but it's also kind of annoying because i
gotta like give these guys [ __ ] money
i gotta be like all right i gotta get
four bucks for love now
that way how much do i love
just four bucks that's all good how much
did they can i buy the can i buy the
bundle or because that's like two bucks
the person actually donated a hundred
dollars and said for love it was that
one thing that you're referring to right
but i'm saying i'll just take four he's
just saying that he'll take four i'll
take seven because the big bundle it's
going up
all right everywhere in my room so i'm
buying the bundle or just go crazy love
get all the get up get it
all the way
i get all the v bucks baby does it come
with a braless wife
yeah buy yourself a bralette sandwich
making wife let's go
from everywhere in my room oh by the way
i see in chat you guys are enjoying the
new let's go emoji
yeah by the way the um the uh uh gift
memberships um have not uh activated on
our account yet which uh that is the
thing that's coming apparently uh
youtube is rolling out uh gift
memberships if you're familiar on twitch
it's similar to their gift subscriptions
where somebody can donate and it will
randomly uh hand out a month of
membership to uh some people in the chat
that aren't members which is pretty cool
uh let's go we enrolled in it and let's
go it's uh it's rolling out soon uh but
apparently it has not been activated on
our account yet so hopefully by friday
oh let's go was calling in on friday
yeah by the way it's not about the seven
dollars
it's like every time you go yo give
money to this person give money this
person i gotta i it's like it's like a
whole thing for me i gotta go
go and send everyone money and if it's
like for what i gotta bring in for all
this cash and give it to you no it's a
whole thing i'm a busy guy i got two
kids oh
my god someone said all hundred was for
you love so i'm not trying to keep your
money oh i don't know
i don't wanna i'm happy i'm giving you
the i'm giving you the hundred all right
i'm not i don't want and then that's the
thing people go you'll give him the
whole hundred and now what i'm like
stealing money from i'm just sitting
here trying to do a show okay i'm not
everyone's accountant
no probably
i don't need it but thank you no i'm
giving you the hundred now because
everyone's like ethan's stealing money
from love
mega donated ten dollars and said this
is for ethan to give to ethan so he can
also buy the fortnite skin without using
donna's credit
shout out
now that's a good that's a good one
right there
[Applause]
yeah i love the let's go guy i'm so
excited to talk to him
seems excited to come on
of course you that guy's just got an
electric energy let's go let's go
we started doing this on on our podcast
chat
because i say we say let's go all the
time it's just a great scene and now you
don't have to say it you just show a
picture of the man's face and you know
what it means yep
okay
all right let's get into the juicy juicy
stuff shall we uh we shall although
we're at 30 so maybe we should do our
ads and then get into the juicy doozy
well dan
that's not a terrible idea
but so maybe before that i should watch
this you think this video's gonna claim
the best buy
the best buy
this this this is pretty impressive man
these
guys try to steal phones from best buy
and the security team like lined up man
and they were ready for war
pretty impressive huh
i guess there's just a lot of uh
stealing happening these days it's so
brazen
yeah that one guy couldn't get his phone
off the string even he didn't even have
anything as far as i could tell this
dude in the black all black
he can't do it
he can't get the phone off flushes
you can't he can't you can't do it what
good are you man
he bailed he didn't have anything look
at that best buy team they're like an
nfl [ __ ] defensive lineup
all of a sudden
i can't imagine those guys are making
enough to be throwing up defense for
this kind of [ __ ] you know yeah look at
the form though they got linebackers
they got like no they look at that look
at he's got his knees up he's ready to
go man he's playing
that one's pretty nuts
anyway the meme is the best spy has a
better defense than your favorite nfl
team which actually looks to be true
though pay
increase this guy's pay man
[ __ ] great dude
oh we just got a donation uh for ten
uh and it says that two dollars are for
me two dollars for ian
two dollars my worst fear two dollars
for zach and two for a b so if you could
you could jot that oh yeah no one for
cam come on man
you can have mine i'll take yours i'll
take the 100 too if you don't want it
yeah yeah just kidding this is my worst
nightmare
two dollars from my hundred to cam okay
thanks thank you no no no you pay do you
pay
no i'm not and then can you actually
give it to me in travelers checks too
doesn't make it yeah one dollar
traveler's check just to make it a
little more easier
i'll still take my my fupacoin
that's now yours i'll redeem football
going if you guys want here's ten
dollars for ethan to give to zach so
because zach doesn't play fortnite and
he they don't want them yeah
so stop
love i bought the ninja skin with my own
money yesterday can you reimburse me
oh here's five dollars uh 30 to love 28
to in 14
to 10 oh now i got to do i know i got to
do the uh i got to calculate percentage
they gave 24 to you though ethan so
you'll be happy to know that 24 of that
five dollars goes straight to you
this is a serious message with peace and
love
after 205 pm on may 11th no more
donations will be distributed to the
crew members oh [ __ ] thank you thank you
any donations addressed to crew members
is going gonna be kept
this is uh i'm warning you with peace
and love i have too much to do
no donations to be given nothing
then this will be fine ten dollars for
the best buy security you didn't specify
oh yeah inside of the car i don't even
know who those guys are how am i gonna
get we'll get over we'll find a way
we'll figure it out yeah
no more donations thank you thank you
all right let's thank our sponsors so we
can talk about brendan
all right thank you to pureology
curology baby i love it curology is a
game changing custom skin care made for
you by dermatology provider they create
a custom prescription cream for your
specific goals whether that's tackling
acne clogged pores skin texture dark
spots fine lines or something else you
start by taking a short online quiz and
uploading photos of your face you take
close-up photos of your face you can see
your pores whatever's going on
and if it's a good fit they're going to
ship you your formula right to your door
and it even has your name on the bottle
so you know it's the real deal
i've been using curology basically
i didn't know about this until we
started working together but i tried it
before we started working on it together
to see if i liked it
i love it
they send me i think it's every month
a moisturizer a face wash and the
dermatology cream
i use it every night
my skin has never felt better i don't
have to fuss and worry about going to a
dermatologist
you know it's just so much easier and
for a lot of people it's a lot more
affordable than
paying a dermatologist to look at your
skin
uh it's the future
i love it the moisturizer and the face
wash are so good too man
it's one of the best i've ever used
get started with curology just like i
did with a free 30-day tryout at
curology.com
h3 just pay five bucks for shipping and
handling that's c-u-r-o-l-o
dot com slash h3 to start your free
30-day trial and you can cancel anytime
prescriptions subject to consultation
very nice
thank you curology love
you and thank you to mint mobile
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by the big wireless
providers if we've learned anything is
that there's always a catch but with
mint mobile gets what's the catch
that there's no catch
so when i first heard about mint mobile
that they offer premium wireless
starting at just 15 bucks i thought
what's the catch
but
yeah i basically already said this but
yeah
there's no camera
dude
there it's just there isn't uh here's
the thing mobile secret sauce is that
they're the first company to sell
wireless services online only and so by
cutting out the cost of retail stores
they're able to pass those savings
directly to you know
dan's talked about his mint mobile many
times we we got dan using mint mobile
uh you love it don't you i do tell them
how much you love it
so much um
same thing
it's the same service you're on you're
using the same backbone for the cellular
service uh it works really well it's
literally the same network that's what's
crazy just for 15 bucks that's right
it's kind of insane don't you think
they're out of their mind like my i
think
they must have lost their minds for
anyone who hates their phone bill mint
mobile offers premium wireless for just
15 bucks a month mobile gives you the
best rate whether you're buying for a
family or just yourself
families start at two lines so all plans
come with unlimited talk and tax plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan and keep
your same number along with all your
existing contacts switch to mit mobile
and get the premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month
to get your new wireless payment for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com h3 that's mintmobile.com
h3
cut your wireless bill to just 15 bucks
a month mint mobile.com
h3
thank you thank you to our sponsors
all right
[Music]
oh dang there's one other thing
i had to show
before we get started in the main
stories now you guys know we had a whole
saga with uh
which is this
putrid disgusting
swedish uh fermented rotted fish
that ian got what'd you get like 1500
out of it the last
little yeah i think so
and man i'm just i can't emphasize how
repulsive this thing is the smell
the feeling
the texture there's one working theory
you know i had a really bad allergic
reaction last week and i could not
figure out why
i had to stop a new medicine i had to
stop eating what i was eating tore my my
life upside down somebody pointed out it
coincided with me licking the fish
i suppose it could be i mean you don't
have any allergies to any other fish
right no you know of um
but then again it is
well i'm still in the process of trying
to figure out what that my my allergic
reaction was to
so i haven't tried taking the medicine
yet but if if it's not the medicine
that'll be the fish
well you gotta try again to find out i
guess yeah so ethan real quick funny
that you know you brought this up this
morning um
sam put an order you know for some
groceries and stuff and we got turkey
jerky
and i smell it
and well
i think you have to smell this too did
anyone else smell this yeah it smells
horrid
yeah it smells more like shitty
chemicals to me so this is just kroger's
turkey smokehouse jerky
yes i mean it looks nasty as hell
that looks like a dog treat
oh oh right
right
it just brings them it doesn't smell
like it but it's there's something
similar that just brings the memory
right back i think it it's like
it right back it's like ninety percent
there like it's like that sweet it just
if i didn't do this the fish thing i
wouldn't be grossed out by that
but it just connects it in my mind in a
way that's it's awful man oh yeah
well the point is
that ian
uh well i thought you had superhuman
strength
and i still do think you have superhuman
strength the way you consume those
this guy is
this is the uh thanos of
sumstromming eating
this is a roofer from leeds uk
and this guy is from another planet man
watch this
okay so i've
asked what should i taste next and uh
the uh
the answer was that
by quite a few people i'm going to
choose one person to do the uh
to receive a hoodie out of them uh
so
will smelly oh you know what this is
this is uh this is english shoe nice
yo
interesting yo can we actually can we
send shoe nice a can of this and try to
get him to eat all can i will pay to see
that he'll do anything on his tick tock
line can you contact him we'll provide
the can we need this stat we just show
shoot us this video and say look there's
someone in the uk who's making you look
like a chump dan are you still blocked
i i might be
nobody's in contact with shoenice well i
had been in contact with him for years
but he got mad at me a while ago and he
and what'd you do
you know how this goes dude i don't know
i think i think i'm on phone number five
for him
yeah so i mean well we've said his name
whenever he he it's like it's like uh
mother mary we thought when you'll juice
a beetlejuice yeah you say his name
three times he shows up he'll be in the
comments he'll leave a thousand comments
but chewie if you're watching email dan
from whatever new email you made and
we'll send you something
never mind you
so wait before we watch the english guy
actually no let's watch careful maybe
watching this with audio he might say
something weird who knows
before we get to that let's see how the
english guy does it how bout can it get
i'm gonna eat they'll go down low
i'm gonna eat the goddamn water
damn i can taste it already
it's like the way he does it he's so
unfazed by the way i got to say ian the
one you did was nastier because it had
bones and [ __ ] in it and guts yeah i
don't think there's bones in that right
those are fillets i saw it said philly
oh that's that's the fancy stuff yeah we
should i like that there's like a less
fancy version it comes out
i didn't know that yeah we gotta get ian
the filet version come on now
oh
i got him
i don't think he's cooked [ __ ] it oh
boys
dude i mean
[Laughter]
i'll give it a ring
dude how can you do that
oh he had to spit it out
all right to our uk
yo
johnny okay
[Laughter]
oh
dude english people are so funny like
bro i didn't even understand what the
[ __ ] they're saying
it's just like oh i love blood
why
no that was awesome
i liked it so he was calm he went in
confident but frankly he couldn't do he
couldn't eat the whole can
so let's see who's the real beast is it
chewy or your boy from leeds oh man
here we go everyone too nice again
oh these were the good old days
all right let's i'm going to cut all
this
did he open it yet i mean it's 12
minutes long shoo
oh he's like panicking
i think he's just doing schtick
when i seen the other dude do them they
were like cutting up like little foam
fish frying again with the twitter
switch when you go to camp this this is
the ones you did so shoei's actually
doing the gnarlier video yeah you can
tell cause the little tail's still on
your parents and
everybody's around you saying yeah you
don't need all your cages when you man
i didn't say real i just
[Music]
this is the same brand
okay well that that's very interesting
to know because if she was doing the
same brand then there's no surprises
here are they breathing
how can they breathe
oh my god
that's it
that's the one you ate ian
it's just so sinister
he seems faced by it it's just a fish
a little sip of a
jack and
cup can't tell if he's doing schtick or
if he's really that faced by it
how could he not be even for sure i mean
the smell is so putrid is that the part
of the hat is our hands in there too
i mean this man ate a bar of deodorant
dan
true
bardian smells good at least
that's true but yeah i mean he ate a
tampon
would you rather eat a tampon
yeah
because i don't
oh my god
i've never seen him affected like this
let's get it all
mind over matter
i don't have a mind
so it don't [ __ ] matter
on your mark
get set
oh my god he can't do it
oh my god
dude no way he can't do it
[Music]
he won't even eat the whole thing
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
what is happening
hold on
oh he kind of likes this
this is
i'm fully captivated by this well god
damn thank you ma'am
that tastes pretty good let's make a
meal out of this i think i got a piece
of chicken here okay okay let's see
where it was okay
yes
undefeated man
take a back seat leads you boys you
cannot be out joker brain
oh you're talking
my apartment hasn't smelled this great
since i don't know when
[Music]
oh man
how's this making you feel ian
forget about the chicken living legend
oh he's throwing some chicken in there
in between
[Music]
a bit of a pallet cleanser
oh okay yeah yeah well if you're pissed
drunk some some feats are easier
is there more fish eating yep three
[Laughter]
he's eating the bones yeah
i gotta say i think she wins the leads
beats the leads guy
one he did it inside
two he like prolonged it man he ate like
you know
i think chewy wins what do you guys
think
yeah i mean he's the goat i mean this is
impressive though this guy gagged you
know he had to abort
well that makes me proud to be american
to be honest
i was afraid
that's right i don't wait my ass bro
i think me and the leeds guy it's like
it's like that meme of the the tiny
domino that leads to the big one and the
small domino is beans on toast
and you knock it and then it's being
able to slam the fish
i think humble beginnings yes
people are saying leeds is better i
don't know i think beast has gotten beat
or the i think you know the leads guy it
was a different brand
it was a flavor
beautiful
yeah that does make it easier we had the
um and chewie we had the you know well
let's do a poll then just to you know we
should sort this out who won chewie or
the leeds guy we she had the ross of the
raw man i mean that's the regular
smegula right there i mean who's more of
a beast
just remember the leads got gagged and
aborted and chewy
he did that in shoei did that in doors
all right pulls up
should we did that indoors
long drawn out
bites
just saying somebody um said that shoe
nice was live and they on tick tock and
they went over and told them that we
were talking about him and to come
comment and then he said uh he's
not he's been banned from uh the chat he
can't chat
so i'm going i'm in the back end right
now
trying to see if i can find him to lift
the box 500 accounts we haven't banned
all of them
that's true maybe just try a different
account well the thing is we kept
yeah i don't know because i remember he
was spamming like crazy like a thousand
i've never seen anything like it like
the craziest fanbots in the world don't
do what he does
yeah
um
eighty percent shoe nice i mean the
people love them yeah
that's the right answer
yeah
eighty percent
[Applause]
the people love you shoei
i can't
it's really
youtube's like
bandless thing is horrible you can't
like search it for somebody so i'm just
going through like hundreds of names
right now trying to find them
i'm trying well they're all shoenice's
accounts or just try another account
shoe yeah that probably is just make a
new one you're very familiar with the
process
all right so
all right let's talk about the brendan's
shop thing
first of all before we get into the
whole
he went on bobby lee's podcast and they
had like a whole conversation about it
but before we get into that
you know there's a lot of brendan schaub
lore
that i didn't know about
from this one subreddit that he thinks
bobby lee runs
said to look at all that
the fighter and the kids subreddit it's
actually important you know about that
because that's like the center of one of
these big
disputes they're having
brendan
and his buddy brian callan who he does
that podcast with are still even after a
pul quo unquote apologizing
are accusing
uh bobby
of masterminding
this subreddit which is great but before
we get into all that
this is i guess an all-time classic
of brandon's
uh here it is for your own watching
pleasure like it was unofficial now by
the way listen i smell i do weird stuff
on screen i'm not gonna i itch my
ear and sometimes i smell it you know i
do i do weird [ __ ] right like i can't
deny it
but
this is next level
i gotta say
if you think i'm this gross just tell me
you know i'm open to that uh
i'm open to exploring that accusation
but you guys tell me what you think so
at the time
apparently it's actually official so the
ufc official talked to mma junkie and
they said that they actually gave him a
three-fight
bonus ban
he knew the ban this whole time he said
it was kind of like he thought they were
doing it but it wasn't really official
but someone told him that there's a band
yeah and why was there band because he
talked [ __ ] before apparently there were
three strikes and one time he ruined a
hotel room i remember that why is it why
did his finger his own mouth
was poop with dog [ __ ] on his finger
have you ever seen anything like that in
your life dude no first of all the way
he did a snap smell on his finger after
who picks the bottom of your shoe
it's nasty
so he clearly has like dog [ __ ] or
something it was unofficial honest [ __ ]
we'll do a play-by-play here
go he has dog [ __ ] on his shoe
picks it off smells it he it smells so
bad he
he he visibly grimaces twice
here he comes another one wow that was
[ __ ] oh he's on screen oh how bad
something got to smell to just go to
yourself
then he says to himself
i need to taste it
now do you think that the wiping of the
shoe was just a cover to taste the dog
[ __ ]
or did he forget that he had dog [ __ ] on
his finger yeah no i think he
i don't think he wanted to eat dog [ __ ]
um i think i'll give him the benefit of
the doubt on that uh you think he did i
think he the i think the rubbing was a
cover was a cover
see i just assumed it was just like he
was like kind of focusing on the
conversation was just kind of passively
doing that and didn't realize
well he just got a pole that would be he
he just picked [ __ ] off his shoes
smelled it was repulsed and the next
thing he does he uses the same hand
to rub something what is that
like dog [ __ ] aside
the way he licks his fingers is just
wild bro
what is that
and then the second time he goes all the
way back like look at this
it's a whole mouthful
crusty petrified dog [ __ ]
look at that
except eating it
what is that
he just committed a sex crime on himself
he just fingered his whole damn mouth
there you have it so that's a classic
uh brendon schaub situation there
i'm trying to find the apex moment of
insertion there it is
look how deep in he is
uh he's knuckle you know he's he's on
the second row here and this one is
eating the purple
so
that one really blew me away and uh
i really wanted to share it with you
guys i i thought it was interesting
for sure
let's see what the comments say uh human
fecal matter of course that's the up
comment
human fecal matter and fecal matter
that's so [ __ ] gross
i mean i yeah people are saying it made
him sick i just thought it was it was
hilarious man
i never seen anything like that my whole
life so i guess shut up
schwab for
opening my eyes
so brian callan
and brendan schaub
who run fighter in the kid podcast they
respond to the bobby situation
and apologize which is really weird
somehow brian callan took all the heat
and brendan was like i didn't do
anything both too yes but bobby am i
just you watch this whole thing zach i
mean is there something worth watching
in here no it wasn't this one i listened
to you watched the tiger belly i believe
can't watch this one though right
yeah it was just him uh taking the blame
and i think the interesting thing was at
one point uh
brian says that
there was apparently a tire belly
employee or something you insinuated
here i've got this timestamp here yeah
this is really weird so he's like kind
of doubling down on it
that's what he's like so he's like i'm
sorry i called him bowling but um
you're you're responsible for for that
old subreddit here reliable source i'm
not a tech guy
it's an ongoing investigation
and i think bob and clyde will also own
up and kyla said this because you know
their emails associated with this and
there's other stuff with social media
telling the truth and i don't have any
problem you know uh owning up to and
facing up to when i and when i am
outside myself no and i appreciate that
but i also think you know i'm going on
tiger belly to address it too it's like
and i think bob and clyde will also own
up and clil said this because you know
their emails associated with this and
there's other stuff associated with well
it's an ongoing investigation
and i will say this guys
an ongoing investigation
into a subreddit posting me and memes
about them
i mean you're basically throwing meat to
the wolves here guys
i think they're too old to be on the air
too dumb and too old to be on the
internet
two i think their podcast should be
called old and dumb
instead of fighter i guess one of them
is fighter one's kid
anybody old and dumb round of applause
please
thank you
thank you i will say this too and this
is what i heard from what i what i can
only accept as a reliable source i'm not
a tech guy i don't do this stuff i don't
know anything about this but what i
heard reliably from what i believe is a
reliable source is since
we have confronted them and i'm not
saying that bobby or kleiland know
anything about this or have anything i
truly believe they don't have anything
to do with it
but somebody on their team does well
the harassment the posts stopped from
that account and that account got
changed
and that's going to be brought up on
tiger belly okay they don't know
anything about red they don't even know
what they're saying of course he
confronts kalila
and kalila completely shuts them down
right kalila is like uh
destroys them with facts and logic ben
shapiro style she had a full timeline of
when the events occurred and
it's just like
throughout the whole tiger belly
interview i
don't think brendan knows
about reddit
neither of them do right right so i
don't know who told them they're like
yeah so this reddit is being run by
someone with a tiger belly email and
they stopped posting and disappeared
when we said it like bro what are you
talking about that doesn't make sense so
in any way i just um
went on to read it in a private browser
and signed up for a fresh account and it
asked for your email and i put in
just random letters it doesn't make you
confirm your email yeah so i know
account right now
guys i'm so sorry to do this but i need
like uh five minutes
so sudden what happened is it grumpy
time
this man
he goes from zero to 100 like nothing
[Music]
grumpy
nice
okay well uh hey everyone
hi dan hello hello
uh doing this
any uh donations of note
there was a shitload everybody was uh
you know kind of trolling sending all
this money for
to be distributed amongst the crew here
we got 69 dollars for ethan nice
epic 69. 50 from jnt uh cam for
crossfaded
uh oh that was the same guy who donated
100 earlier i never thanked you thank
you gmt thank you very much thank you
jnt
hyundai for love another hundo for the
brawless wife and 50 for crossfaded cam
wow that's 250
buckaroo
right there i'll tell you what i'll get
crossfaded again
at zack's upcoming show at the viper
room oh
you know he's too shy to plug it so i'm
going to plug it for him yeah he's too
shy thank you yeah he's a shy guy is
this my lead-in to plug it i guess so
yeah
i have something i want i've been
wanting to share actually cam actually
can you help me can you hand me this
stack over here you're in la hold on one
sec
[Music]
well why are you doing that no it's
so pretty
no has nothing to do with you is that
okay
that's fine
sorry
so there is someone in the fan base
an artist who goes by the name
idrawnyc
and uh they've been featured on our
social media sunday uh fan art post
quite a few times
and they did all these amazing pieces
for the whole crew here's one of love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh but really talented and uh yeah um
actually my girlfriend ally liked them
so much that she ordered prints of all
of them
love that picture and framed them
uh so that we can hang them up in the
office and i just want to give a shout
out to idrawnyc
thank you so much for this out i believe
that that is their tag on all the uh
socials uh here's ian and sam
there's gonna be a
artist feature
an artist feature
of him tomorrow on this oh very nice yes
[Music]
oh there we go my whole background cool
background that
was yeah
uh this is probably the goofiest one but
it really cracks me up
it's the whole game including the green
m m that's beat out and the uh
it's awesome guys
uh
here's one of me and ally
awesome god damn it there's so much
green
put the totoro characters down here so
anyways
just wanted to shout them out uh here's
olivia
[Music]
i believe they do commissions uh so if
uh you like their style um hit him up
yep very cool his ad is i draw nyc on
instagram there you go
a little artist feature segment there oh
uh ab just sent this uh this is their
latest one
uh
for the fight
you getting that uh did you see it you
see it yeah
okay
so very cool so shout out to their
family
uh
and
and that's it
um we really miss you ab good luck on
the fight this weekend says the donation
can i uh do my plug now dan uh hold on
just a few more things no i'm just
kidding go ahead so yeah i am playing
again live music it was great seeing
everyone that came out um playing at the
viper room this time it's a little
smaller tickets are gonna go fast um
link for tickets of my social and i'm
doing something special where i'm
offering 50 tickets and doing a
acoustic show before the main show so
that'll be that'll be fun so uh that's
awesome uh ticket links are my socials
and uh yeah it's gonna be fun it's gonna
be a good time
i was doing a little reading before the
show is uh the viper room where rivers
phoenix died that is the place yes
allegedly haunted yeah maybe the ghost
of rivers river phoenix will show up to
the show
that's not funny
well that's not funny at all captain hey
who said i was joking he could he could
actually shut up okay well that's just
gonna be a matter of fact that's true
sex god man i hope he shows up i hope so
too sorry he was a sexy guy he was an
icon
okay
[Music]
all right all right
well this is a long grumpy somebody just
said uh ending an 80-hour work week in
six days of health care with you all
peace and love love the r2 good luck a.b
80 hours that's too many hours
my friend that's too many hours i am
sorry that uh you're having to do that
that's that's not fun isn't that like
illegal
uh it's not necessarily illegal i hope
you're getting [ __ ] crazy overtime
for it at the very least but healthcare
maybe it should be illegal you said
health care
they they said that they said health
care uh day six days of health care with
y'all i'm assuming that means they work
in health care maybe they're a nurse or
something well shouts i know that they
do work horrible hours so shout out to
them yeah shout out to them
uh favorite fish song guys i don't think
there's any fish fans here
shut the [ __ ] up think again okay cam's
a fish fan they are a poor man's
grateful dead yeah
for that
i was a big fan in high school
i'm not going to argue with you about
them being a poor man's grateful dead
but i still loved him in high school
look i will i will say trey anastasio
[ __ ] shreds i'll give him that but if
i'm gonna listen to jam band [ __ ] i'm
either gonna listen to the grateful dead
or dave matthews and that's just how it
is they've mapped you i'm not so sure
about the date matthew you don't like
dave matthews band
what's wrong with you aside from that
are they considered a jam band yeah
they're considered a japan
i've never ever heard them
classified as a jam before really
matthews band they have like a cult dead
type following well maybe that's true
but i mean
differently each performance oh okay
yeah it does sound like they got some
jam bananas there i mean almond brothers
i'd consider them a jam ban southern
rock jam bam oh for sure yeah
i had no idea i'm not up to date on my
dave matthews lore apparently well you
[ __ ] he [ __ ] schlops dude
i just wanted to one up the 80 hour guy
ending one month long no day off streak
i mean
i just
feel bad for you
it's horrible
thank you
thank you for being you i mean
do what you got to do i guess but man
that's brutal hope he gets some rest i
mean i used to be that guy i remember
back when i was working in
uh production
i worked one week where i had
i think it was four
like 18 hour days in a row
um
it's not fun it's not sustainable hell
hellish
so um
hopefully you don't have to continue
doing that yeah somebody said not a flex
yeah i and i don't think they meant it
as a flex but yeah it's just uh
that's brutal man
that's brutal
do you like jimmy page of course [ __ ]
of course
you did a
zeppelin cover at the mint show didn't
you yeah we closed with a whole lot of
love right that was not planned we just
jammed that yeah
you once played a rain song for me on
your instagram i did yeah that was that
was special for cam thank you very much
it was perfect how about that
i gotta say i'm so stoked to sit here
right now ab your seat's going to be
back for you i'm just warming your seat
but you know this is a very star
structure i like you better there man no
i know i like a b better here but i'm
just happy to to be here i like looking
at the back your head but you know i
love ab but i love you cam i love you
too zach and i i love uh i can feel
love's presence again all the army
gloves
right behind me
i said dan can you talk about what the
interview was like with ethan uh to be
honest it really wasn't one i kind of i
kind of just fell into this whole thing
i've told the story before but
um they were working with somebody
uh that they had reached out to through
twitch because at the time they were
streaming on twitch and um he was a
buddy of mine who i had done a lot of uh
work with in the past
and he had set him up with the whole
studio but couldn't stay on to be you
know their permanent dude so he hit me
up and said have you ever heard h3
before they're starting a podcast i said
yes i actually am familiar
and he said great uh can you be here
tomorrow or something like that it was
like the next day and i was out of town
working on a gig and so i flew back and
the next day came in and the rest is
history and it really just kind of
happened
i'm gonna come
come come i'm so sorry guys i don't know
why
that keeps happening
it's all good happening more and more
it's become more and more common but
we have fun we have our little uh i was
trying your hour over here
yeah you guys were what do you guys talk
about my absence uh
a bunch of stuff we were talking about
uh jam bands we were talking i gave a
shout out to this artist uh that uh sent
us all this uh fan art and um
talked about
zach's uh next show at the viper room
phoenix river phoenix is uh haunting the
viper room and is also
a sex icon evidently according to zach
the ghost of river phoenix is a sex
cycle that's right yeah yes
sex ghost sexuals wow
[Music]
i was trying to sit on it you know
sometimes you sit on it and it goes away
i think everybody knows about that
sometimes it doesn't you know and uh
i was trying my best man to hold that
thing in but
you feeling okay no i feel totally fine
all right cool yeah just i don't know i
just had to evacuate
my pants
people are saying ibs batty thank you
guys yeah
grumpy
i had to make a very grumpy grumpy
was it easy coming out or was it yo
ethan in the title of new philly d video
hit me with that fortnite song
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so anyway uh yeah i don't see the new
video yet sometimes it takes a bit to
show up on the channel page
so were we finished with this clip or
the was this the dog [ __ ] clip or oh oh
no this is the evening we're just being
honest this drama
i'm way too old to deal with it but but
i [ __ ] up and so once again here's
what i have to say
i'm the guy director hated me i take
full responsibility bobby i love you i'm
sorry i was wrong i was 100 wrong you
didn't deserve that i should have given
you the benefit of the doubt i should
have spoken to you first how the [ __ ]
did i think a guy as sweet as you as
special as you as giving as you as funny
as you
would ever do something like that i i
how would i think that i got [ __ ]
deranged i was
isn't awesome how brian's the one
apologizing and brandon's just sitting
there like a [ __ ] log it's so bizarre
but i guess it's because they're
specifically trying to make it about
this like reddit account issue rather
than the fact that he
tried to slide into clyo's dms
that's the framing that i'm getting is
well brendan's denying all that
right the dms the hitting on
brandon didn't really apologize for
anything brian apologized for
calling them aggressively but they're
really still backing up with this bobby
lee is the
someone at tiger belly which is what
like three people i mean
they're basically accusing his their
producer of it because there's nobody
else they said it wasn't bobby it wasn't
kalila i mean who else is there there's
gilbert and george and i think that's
the whole team so they're saying yeah
yeah so they're accusing one of their
dear friends
i i actually have a stunning apology
uh it's actually me i uh
oh [ __ ] i'm the mastermind behind uh
fighter and the kid subreddit
i just don't understand it's me also not
a crime
right i have been caught trust me i've
been already sued once for brian
cavanaugh tried to sue me for the same
thing brian
ryan
ryan ryan kavanagh
literally put reddit memes in his
lawsuit against us and that one is gone
firsthand experience
you know
so i don't even know what the [ __ ] you
guys are on about
i was listening and i i didn't do my due
diligence yeah it's it is a good apology
i agree though he's he he's giving a
heartfelt sincere apology to bobby which
is nice i thought it was very mature
i don't like that they're still behind
this bobby lee
tiger belly attack i didn't
like you it's unlike me but i'll see you
but i was so traumatic about my friend
and i was so [ __ ] traumatized because
i've never told you about it but then i
don't talk about i got scared it's awful
i got scared dude when i get scared i
fight i know you do you know i i'm not i
don't i don't i don't [ __ ] back down
i'm going to fight but dude aren't you
too old to be with this song
the whole thing is just like
a fighter dude how testosteroned up they
are
when i get scared i fight and you know
that about me dude it's a fight in the
kid dude i'm a i always i'm a fighter
you know that about me knock your teeth
out man
you got to be careful about how you
fight agree but here's the way this
thing ends is there's obviously love
between us and tiger belly and i'm going
to go on there and say my truth and
they're going to say how we hurt them
and that's fine and hopefully we can
squash all of it
and even kaleila goes all right well if
we find out who it is what he wants to
do
and this this goes for anybody out there
i i told clyde and bobby i just want to
stop
i
i want nothing else i'm there's no legal
action there's no threats i never want
i will have to say this too i'm confused
because on tiger belly he said that he
spent 500 000
of dark money to
anyway okay so whatever
they want people to stop hating on them
on the internet me too man that's my
wish yeah hey message to everybody all
my haters listen
i just want it to stop
yeah i think that might work have you
ever tried that tactic
actually not asking absolutely not guys
who've been leaving me and comments
about me and making videos about me i
just have one message please stop
please stop it's worth a shot i suppose
i don't like it
are saying brian callum has some
allegations against him in that
i don't know about that
and i don't want to get into that is
this too serious
without having enough knowledge about it
but anyway that was what they said and
then what got real interesting is when
brandon went on
tiger pal tiger belly
and they talk about us
um
here it is
you got am i crazy or when i clicked
this link someone made a post about
ethan on the subreddit
and bobby isn't happy with ethan when i
click it it opens the uk guy eating
uh fish
which i'm happy to watch again
actually why don't i just go to the
subreddit
i see the correct link there's why does
it oh every time i click it look at this
i believe you and my google doc might be
this guy hang out
fish guy all right anyway i'll find it
right here weird so this is the main
reason why i want to talk about this so
here there's this narrative
building by the way that i've noticed
and i see it on our subreddit now
which i don't i don't think it's fair to
me so i want to speak speak up for
myself a little bit
yikes sounds like bobby isn't too happy
with ethan okay
so here's a little extra when i went to
showed up to 83 podcast
this wasn't even in our
world it wasn't in our view our mind you
know i mean and i don't know him and i
have no ill will tortoise i don't know
him but from my understanding from
talking to mutual friends of ours that's
what he does right yeah but you know we
had done the podcast drama yeah but we
had done that podcast
i don't know
okay well i'll i'll let the whole thing
play did someone find the timestamp of
from the original of when we started
talking about it yes it's uh in the dock
it's uh
if you look in the section
um
oh oh you're right thank you all right
i'll continue many of times four he's
done ours him and his wife
ela and they're lovely they're lovely
and i don't know
people they're lovely i don't know them
you know um and you know it wasn't in
our you know and even on the drive back
from there we just
were in we were in
a state of shock because
you know i'm not one to
you know
air my dirty laundry on air okay and it
was a private matter and once he brought
it up there was just no way to get out
of it i tried you know i mean i was a
thinking machine i mean it was just like
spinning right in honesty i didn't try
that hard yeah yeah i know i was willing
to do it and i'll tell you why and i
believe you guys and the same thing with
schultz when he goes hey i want to bring
up the hate i didn't know he's going to
bring up
this so particular issue with us yeah
and i said nothing but compliments you
things i wanted to move on which we did
you know yeah yeah so uh and um just one
last thing is is that so you know we
said things that i was going to die to
the grave with um
you know
my relationship with h3 is on my own
private of matter you know i didn't see
it but i but i heard completely that you
guys were caught off guard yeah and also
you know people i'm just responding to
the things that i've read online saying
that why did you do in the first place
you have to understand that i had done
it before and it was never like that i
mean we they had done ours and i'd like
to defend ethan and eli here and i love
that um you know they're attacking them
they asked the question
and
i don't know about you and maybe that's
how you felt i don't want to invalidate
your feelings on it but i i was okay to
talk about it i'll get to why i was okay
to talk about it
all right
are we sure we have 10 minutes
so i want to say i don't think bobby's
trying to say anything you know
but i i don't know
i get accused of a lot of stuff okay
especially with the interview like that
and i've definitely been guilty of
pushing people too hard to talk about
things that they're uncomfortable with
in the past
for sure
but i've worked a lot on my you know
interviewing skills and listening and
being more
sensitive to making the guests
comfortable and talking about things
they want
and i just feel like you know again i
don't think bobby's trying to do
anything there's there's no problem or
anything i'm also just responding to
comments i see
on the subreddit
and comments i see on the internet
like a lot of his fans are just people
from that world they're like
ethan pushed them
he blindsided them and all
this and i feel like i was really
sensitive
i didn't push them at all i really just
listened i feel like i really didn't
push them at all so i don't know i mean
again i wasn't trying to drama bait or
anything it wasn't even a big plan of
the show i barely mentioned it i mean
here
the fact that all opened up like that
came as a shock to me too i mean
i was there for it obviously right i
mean my job
as a host is have an interesting
memorable show but
i by no means feel like i bended
anyone's
leg or had an alternative
agenda going into that i mean here you
can see this is where it starts
highly of themselves i'm like red flags
not funny something's wrong here yeah
yeah
there are comments that do that you want
to
name someone brendan schwab
just cracking a meaningless joke i mean
there was no
here
i'm a beast
wait we can't talk about it yeah we can
talk about that
if you
no i would there you go she opened the
door and by the way kalila was very
gracious and spoke up for us
but she opened the door she says if you
want i said shirtless you know what do
you want to say she has something she
wants to say love to talk about what why
don't you want to talk about brendan
schwab but you're down
so
brendan shop
i literally didn't even know his name i
genuinely thought his name was schwab
um you know i was only familiar a little
bit with this whole situation from doing
some research to prepare for the
interview just knowing what was going on
with them
well here's what i'll say about brendan
schwab schwab
oh yeah yeah
i call him a schwab because he looks
like a uh
a schwa you know like is that they call
those schwabs in the air yeah uh swab
okay
you gently do it but this is on you this
is on here okay so brandon
and that's it he's a comedian
again bobby had plenty of outs too i get
and we kept giving him out and either
was like
ela said a few times you know you don't
have to talk about this if you don't
want to
and if he had ever told me can we stop
talking about this and i would have
absolutely respected it so
i feel like i've come a long way as an
interviewer and there's a lot of like
bad
precedents that i'm trying to overcome
and so i feel like it's a little unfair
to characterize it like in that way
again i don't think bobby's trying to
say anything and kalila was very
uh
very gracious i'm just saying that for
all the commenters who were like i
blindsided them and twisted their arms
into talking about things they were
uncomfortable with you know yeah which
was a minority
i saw lots of those comments um not on
the c right in response to the subreddit
but i see people all the time and like
brandon said that i'm just this is what
i do i don't even know what that means
this is what i do i have people on and
blindsiding them with drama
bait i mean that's not what i do
at all
you know i like to gossip don't get me
wrong but
no you
but i'm respectful of our of our guests
i try to be you know
podcast with uh
two other very funny ladies called uh
trash tuesday okay with esther pavitzki
and annie yeah great show thank you
love all three of you guys
my heart's beating because i want to be
delicate about this 100 percent okay yes
you should tread lightly i will tread
lightly so you guys were doing a show
and you said that someone you guys knew
okay was trying to pick hold on you
don't want to even say
well just correct me where i'm wrong we
don't need to stress you guys how it
it's going to distress him because
okay go ahead ethan
you okay bobby
i mean i don't know what
you know
so i don't know
well it had me questioning myself
because i wanted to go back and see it
and be like
did i pressure them when they didn't
want to talk about i don't think so
actually
so there you go
you know
uh
this is another great moment i don't
know uh what do you guys think but
obviously i was afraid
that people were going to be mad at me
coming out that
i mean genuinely i was just outraged by
the whole story because it was so
outrageous and i love bobby so much
and this guy brendan schaub is such a
bully
you know
but there you go i don't know um
i'm just reading comments to see what
people
are saying
anyway
there's another thing that brendan's
doing like
he's been doing this thing his new
special's out
and it's just horrible it's not funny at
all
and uh while people are making reviews
of it calling it you know not funny and
he's blocking them all
people just put a lot of time and effort
into video essays
and he's just blocking all of them so
he's up to all kinds of [ __ ]
i mean there's a lot more reasons for me
to and that's in my wheelhouse right
like i mean that's exactly
that's kind of my whole
schtick that's like my triggers when
people abuse copper in free speech
i made an ethan klein video about it
actually
but just trying to defend this creator
who got blocked by brandon
but anyway there's some other great
moments from the podcast
one being that uh
kalila asks brendan
if he knows
how red it works
this is what's interesting explain this
however you want
when i notified you guys of the
harassment and going back to tiger belly
that account stopped posting took the
tiger belly email off and changed it
it's never posted again do you know how
reddit works
no
there you have it that's awesome
and you know i resent that he keeps
saying this dumb [ __ ] it's just so
stupid what is he accusing them of well
he
he kept saying that he was going to show
them he was going to show them they're
all on his phone these this proof this
document and they wouldn't show bobby
and kalila before the show
so
the whole episode was like i'm going to
show you after i'm going to show you
after i'm going to show you after and so
bobby kalila asked him will you come
back on
and it's almost like he was hesitant to
do that
he has nothing there's
nothing to have exactly the accusation
makes no sense if you know anything
about reddit right and like dan said
before i [ __ ] my pants
you could go do it yourself i could go
make an account that that with the email
bobby lee at tigerbelly.com right they
don't make you verify
your email address
but even then none of that is public
anyways too yeah there's there's no
still baffles me you can't let me ask
you somebody's email is there a way if
you have the username
okay if you try to um
uh reset your password is there a way to
get the email address
like let's try that
let's go to that's a good question let's
go to a random user
you know
i'll just do it with my uh
account that i just made so you get the
username you just get a random username
here show it on the screen let's see
this is what he paid five hundred
thousand dollars for i'm doing it for
free right now for you uh brandon
our incognito window we'll go to reddit
so you get the username then you say i
forgot my password can you show it then
yeah good thank you all right so
[Music]
here galactic bees
wait this is your account no i'm in an
incogni i'm not logged in at all right
now
but due to yeah do it too i don't want
to i don't want to realize because i
just typed random letters i don't
remember the account that i did oh i
don't want to i don't want to try to
hack someone else's account well if you
give me one minute i can just uh okay do
it again so
let's do some psyops here
uh was there anything else um
interesting you want to comment on zach
from that podcast i just it just felt
like he kept saying brendan that he had
this proof this evidence but he was
really hung up on the reddit haters
right he i think you know that's the
core of this that's the the crux of this
but
i just don't think he knows how to use
reddit and i think that's
the issue with this he saw the name some
email tiger belly or some [ __ ]
and that's his hang up with it
yeah try it with um
try it with love's account it's just h3
out that's your username right
yes all right so let's see if we can
hack into
and get love's email address
so there's this hater on the subreddit
called h3out
oh i immediately no you can't because
you have to know the email address
associated with the account to even get
to the reset but can you click forget
forgot gmail
uh
maybe not no forgot to use it it says
you have to put in the username and
email address to get the reset the
password wait go back let's see if
there's other options
so can you do forgot username
then you'd have to do the email yeah
and then if you type in like type in
love's email
which is whatever
and then email it doesn't you just have
to check the email it's not going to
show you the user right there's
literally no way to know what someone's
email address is in fact i'm so sure
that would be insane if you could
because that would be like a huge breach
of privacy right so i mean the only way
to actually get that information seems
like it would be like subpoena the
government actually yeah
usually you can get the first letters of
the gmail on any other given platform
like twitter for example you can get
the first letter of the before act and
the first after
right but that's what i'm saying is on
reddit when you go
and say hey i can't remember my password
i need to reset you need the username
and the email associated with it to even
get to that screen i mean reddit is a
lot about
uh anonymity so there's a lot of people
that post weird [ __ ] on there and they
don't want people to know their email if
you could find someone email you could
easily find their identity
i think that would be a really well
known thing
and so
clearly there's no way to find a posters
email and also even if you could they're
not doing anything illegal you're it's
free speech to post [ __ ] on [ __ ] the
internet ryan cavanaugh tried to sue me
for memes on our subreddit and it got
thrown out
so
you know
also from the uh the tiger belly podcast
uh brendan talks about how he gets
rogan's advice for everything
he gets rogan's advice on anything
and
it's just he's this boy it's daddy rogan
you know
you wanna he said that in which podcast
the tiger belly one see i wonder if
that's a subtle
kind of
threat
it is because i apparently
he flew out to austin to go do joe's
show
and in that time he was discussing it
with him and
kalila feels that there were some words
shared about her to rogan
what i would guess the dialogue is
behind the scenes
is a lot of those guys don't like me
like the joe rogan and all those guys
like brandon said
uh mutual friends of mine say that he's
just a drama he just causes drama and
that's what he does
so i think they're probably like bobby
went on this drama podcast
and started all this [ __ ] and someone
like joe rogan would be like it's so
trashy that he went on there and aired
the dirty laundry
even though the real crime
is that [ __ ] uh of course those two
numbskulls are bullying this
this bobby for nothing something he
didn't even do
but that's what it is right it's a boys
club it's all [ __ ] toxic [ __ ] show
i don't think tom no tom sagar is my
friend he doesn't give a [ __ ] about that
stuff
but joe wood i feel like but any i don't
know anything about joe i don't know him
but there you go
uh
i just wanted to speak up a little bit
for myself there
um
there you have it
by the way is there anything else to say
about this topic you guys think
no
i mean
i think you've
you've said your piece i know it was
bothering you that people were
accusing you of uh instigating this
whole thing but
you know you're
you're kind of just a bystander to all
this right they were i mean there's
evidence that was willing to talk about
it yeah it's almost like they wanted to
they wanted to get off their chest
[Music]
i i had no plan to get involved in that
stuff
like i just knew about it i made a
little brendan shobb joke
and the whole floodgate's open by the
way there's a website hold on let's do a
deeper
search here there's a website called
skid search if you can pull that up dan
apparently someone said you can it shows
your ready email so let's see
uh it's something you have to register
for so uh give me a minute to uh sign up
so according to this user there's an
advanced
program
[Music]
we're hacking the mainframe
brandon you owe me 500 000 for the
psyops
i'll send you a check in the mail
um i will say too on the fighter and the
kid they were talking about
that what really upset brendan was that
he was getting threats and stuff too
which he obviously doesn't deserve and
that [ __ ] sucks but i don't think
bobby or any of anybody on tiger belly
was threatening brendan
on reddit dude of course not yeah it's
the charge is so ridiculous yeah
also not not to exonerate um brandon
from anything but in the tiger belly
apparently that brian kaelin was like
said some truly truly awful names and oh
really what did he say did they say they
didn't give specifics but it was some
some
ill terms about klyla and um
he was just going off and
bobby when they were talking about it
like you know brian says he uh
apologized bobby just like it almost
seemed like he was
done with
him ryan or bobby
bobby was done with brian caitlin well
of course bro yeah like what the [ __ ]
yeah
um
i don't know
the whole thing is so ridiculous on the
on the on those guys's
sides
are you getting any progress there dan
how's it looking yeah i just got signed
up and
it has this thing
database search engine
can you pull it up username yeah
all right so here's here's skid search
h3out is your reddit name right
so let's see if we can get
some intel on this i mean don't show
this i don't know
let me show my ap and [ __ ] that's if
like stuff is leaked you think that we
can get your ip well that would be good
so what they do is like they they clap
they take a bunch of data databases
that's been leaked and they put it in a
place where people can search for it
i see i see well okay so tell me if
there's an alarming well nothing came up
when i searched it i mean so h3o nothing
came up nothing came out all right so
show it
well it it doesn't even there's nothing
there's literally nothing this is i
don't know this is just a random chapter
who said this i don't think it's so yeah
i mean i just wanted to follow it up but
there you go we couldn't get the email
from skid search
there you have it
yeah it's a date the scrubber someone
said in a shed
so i don't know there it is
by the way you guys might notice
god
i've got this tick that's killing me my
throat is like
torn up
some of you guys i heard i saw some
people complaining about it
uh
this sound here listen listen quietly
you hear that
that's what i've been doing all day
it's a tick
clearing my throat my throat is like so
torn up i don't know where it came from
but it's like
really bad it's like one of the worst
ones i've had in a while
my throat is in so much pain
and i can't stop doing it
and it's really annoying to listen to
which makes it even worse for the
podcast
you know i didn't even realize that you
could hear it until once i started
listening
and i was like oh my god you can hear
that's really annoying
and i was able to stop doing it for a
while
sometimes just knowing that people can
hear it almost makes it worse
right because you because i like
desperately don't want to right now do
it yeah
and now it's just really bad man so
sorry to people who uh
find that sound annoying
and sorry to the people who i just
brought attention to that sound
as well right now
but oh god it's i'm trying not to do it
and i need to stop doing it because my
throat is so damaged
okay
there you have it guys we found the vlog
to be offensive i'm sorry you did for
those of you who didn't find it to be
offensive i'm sorry they did
such a great apology
i love that that's one of the best fan
all-timer
[Applause]
all right so now up next we got this
fresh and fit colon which is sounding
really good
yeah uh you uh let me um
let me get her on there is wednesday
no actually today is wednesday so very
good we should play that at the top of
our wednesday shows zach oh yeah i i'm
incorporating it now and do the uh off
the rails oh i didn't notice was that in
today's video oh excellent excellent
oh
actually before we start
we found a really staggering discovery
about fit
you want to tell the story anne because
it's pretty good
uh
yeah i just i saw on on twitter trending
today people were talking about
uh meg the stallion and tory lanez and
it was mainly people saying that
meg is a liar
and you know
i i just i don't know people are making
a lot of assumptions
in that regard but i was following to
see why people were saying it this time
because they keep having new things
and then i saw someone go
well i saw
proof in a video
and it was really legitimate because the
video was by a guy who is an ex-federal
agent and he knows about this sort of
stuff
and they named a channel and i went to
go look the channel up and it was uh it
was fit
mind-blowing
he has this youtube channel called fit
it
and so what is he even on about by the
way how do you lie about being shot
didn't he get arrested like isn't this
was proven by the police i mean how do
you lie about that there there's like an
ongoing um
case regarding it and a lot of people
are saying
they're both saying that each other is
lying so i don't know it's ongoing right
okay
well what's extra disturbing about the
fact
that fit is an ex-federal agent
get this
he used to work in the human trafficking
department
so he claims well i mean i think it is a
legitimate claim because i found
somebody had posted some uh because
other people were questioning
whether or not he was legitimately a
federal agent and uh
found some
you know public filings of affidavits
that he had signed on to and stuff and
he even described himself as working in
the human trafficking or uh
department or one i'd like to know why
he left you know like uh what kind of
pretty young to uh retire isn't he a
little young
you know in the human trafficking
division sometimes cops gets uh you know
they get fired for stealing drugs from
evidence yeah he got he got he actually
got arrested for stealing the evidence
aka a human
being he actually mentions it if you uh
this time stamp if you play it it kind
of has a little intro
i am special agent with home this is uh
this is from one of his documents yes
he worked for the homeland security
investigation and have been employed
since 2013 i'm currently signed with the
human smuggling group
in miami where i'm responsible for
conducting investigations regarding
violations of federal law particularly
those laws found in whatever those codes
are
so on top of related to human smuggling
yeah on top of being a uh red pill guru
uh podcaster he's also a cop so cool guy
i'm deep undercover by the way this is
the guy who has
cobra the human trafficker on his
podcast and talks about what a great guy
he is
this guy openly talks about his revenue
stream being generated from human
trafficking
and then
fit the federal agent in human
trafficking
is celebrating him on his show is this
really the people that are
in our in our law enforcement
yes this is a man who's supposed to be
advocating for women in a human
trafficking
division that's scary dude
that's scary
and now he's trying to you know
now he's trying to
monetize it i'd love to know why he left
that job
holy [ __ ] maybe he talks about one of
his videos i mean we literally found
this
ten minutes before we went live today
mind-blowing yeah mind-blowing discovery
the [ __ ] are we looking at that moment
um i did i did see a clip clip and i can
try to find it where he says that they
didn't like his youtube channel so
that's why he resigned
wait what yeah i can try to find that
again real quick what the fridge is let
me find it so they're like they're like
wait dude you can't be friends with the
human traffickers and then work on the
division you see the conflict of
interest
there's a clip go look for the clip
maybe that's why i left
i don't know that
definitely raised some red flags so
anyway that was this is like a little
good
uh
background there but
who we have calling in today is this
really interesting uh woman
who is one of these guests on the panels
she appeared on
the january 22nd episode called
can a man or woman have a side piece
great discussion
she was 19 at the time she was invited
onto the podcast
and she didn't know who they were
at the time she was on the podcast she
was 19
fit was 35
and fresh was 28.
her friend had been seeing fresh
and our guests flew our guests flew down
to miami to visit her friend
uh walter invited them walter's
fresh walter invited them on the podcast
and hold up fresh right yes yes i got
them confused i'm sorry go ahead first
of all please encourage all the girls to
drink before and during the podcast
that's interesting she was 19.
upon arriving the studio our guests had
to sign so that she signed a media
release and was briefed on certain
things don't interrupt myron they tell
them that before they go on
what the fridge
oh weird
wait for your turn to speak
no shoes in the studio
what has he got little cameras down
there to get little spy footage of their
feet
and don't look at your chat or camera
during the show i think that's that's
interesting but don't interrupt myron is
pretty pathetic and wait for your turn
to speak
well we've seen examples when we've
reacted to their content before that
when
when he he feels like he's being
interrupted he he gets very tricky he
left the one that went viral was that
girl right he did dude well anyway let's
let's talk to her because she has a lot
of interesting all right uh i emailed
her a moment ago uh with the link and
said hop on so uh
just waiting
for her to jump on the gun oh oh she's
not ready
uh
should be here any second now but yeah
don't have her yet is he in the lobby
no alrighty
well
yeah record scratch roman
well apparently let's see what's on his
um
his uh
fed yeah let's explore a little bit
man i love that his his youtube channel
got him fired
fed it
uh
she is in the lobby
let's sort by most popular
so whatever most popular upload why king
von would spend life in prison alive
to be honest i don't know any of these
people he's talking about
jeffrey epstein
okay love your insight i'm sure you have
a really good insight on that one
he's the only guy being like jeffrey
epstein was 100
innocent i don't know and i know because
i'm a federal agent
that man did absolutely nothing wrong
and i've been to his island many times
and i never saw anything out of
out of sorts there
um so she is in the lobby if you'd like
me all right let's do it all right one
second
hello hello how are you
i'm good and you very good thanks for
calling
yes of course i've been a big fan for a
while so it was convenient that i went
on fresh and fit so
thank you so much so
uh so basically this was january the
beginning of the year
oh i can hear myself am i on speaker or
something you're coming in real nice and
crispy
hold on i have my earpods with me i
could put my earpods in okay yeah that'd
be great
yeah so
um
let me know when you're uh
all situated there
can you guys hear me better now
uh you sound great
yeah i think the echo is gone
so you appeared at the beginning of the
year now how did you end up on the show
so basically what had happened was um i
had uh she's my best friend one of my
best friends um she lived out where i
live in right now i live in new jersey
so um she moved out to miami around like
november september of last year
and um
when she moved out to miami she was like
she had her own apartment so she was
looking for something to financially
like support her
so she went on this this site um where
there it was like a dating type of site
and you know
it was for
financially you know relationships
yeah
and um so she uh she met fresh on that
uh site too that's and
yeah they i'm pretty sure they
previously had gotten exposed for that
like i think a year ago how they had
like a whole dating
show but they were found on this app so
it was kind of contradicting but
um she had hung out with him a few times
but it was mostly like they were more
friends than anything
so she got pretty close with him and um
she ended up flying me out to miami to
visit her for about like a few days
and that's when i had met fresh myself
so he i'm not going to lie like he is a
very nice person fresh seems very nice i
mean he and he just you know he's just
kind of there right i mean he's not a
very sharp guy and you know god bless
him for that right
yeah and and i also we also found out
that he actually owns the podcast it's
not byron myron's fit by the way
okay so we actually maybe you can shed
light on some
questions we had because we noticed that
fresh had a lot more followers
and he seems to be wealthy and i was
wondering how how did he get what's his
background
so basically um
what had also by the way like i i spoke
to sam when i before i came on but the
reason why i called in was because i saw
your your videos for a while and you
guys were asking questions that like i
knew the answers to and i was like i
have to call you guys in but basically
he um
he's the one that recruits like him and
his team recruit the girls but it's
mostly like walter that goes to like
these events at clubs so he goes to the
clubs and he's the one that goes out
there to like i guess like advertise
them and stuff i don't know exactly what
he i don't know but he's the one that
goes out and myron just like stays
behind at home it doesn't really do
anything so like walter
yeah that's so and so fri fresh is
actually the brains behind the operation
he's the secret mastermind he's the
genius he he's running the operation
picking coconuts and barbados
i mean coconuts and barbados man it's
wednesday my dudes
yeah
yeah he like he goes out and and the
craziest part too is that um he went out
to clubs and my friend had tagged along
with him a few times because he invited
her out with him but he doesn't drink
neither does myron but they go out to
these clubs to like i guess like speak
to people and like they don't drink like
a sip of liquor like they refuse
that's so [ __ ] up well you know why
they're trying to find drunk girls to
take advantage yeah
holy [ __ ] that's so creepy
yeah
but um when i had flown out to miami on
my first day there i slept the whole day
but my second day me and her had gone
out to um to like a little hotel pool
party and um after that we went he
invited us back to his apartment to have
like just to hang out with him and stuff
because i had talked to him over the
phone a few times but when we went to
his apartment we spoke to him i met his
dog and stuff he was very cool down to
earth and then my friend had asked like
if we could be on the podcast and he was
like okay like you guys can come on so
we went on like two days later and then
that's when i had my whole experience
like before during and after on the
podcast
so what i'm what i'm hearing so far is
fresh is the brains he's actually a
sweet guy which i believe
you know
i think the whole funny thing that
you're touching on is how they complain
about women being gold diggers but
they're finding women to date on gold on
sugar daddy websites it makes no sense
and like the more i get into this stuff
like i kind of had like my own debate
with myron off camera like it's just
like
their whole they're very i could say fit
is a very insecure man from my
experience oh yeah oh yeah but like it's
it's like it's a very hypocritical
podcast i mean it's already known but
like it's disgusting i don't know i just
can't stand them
all right so tell me about the day
because i know you had some interesting
uh run-ins with myron aka fit
so tell me about the day the podcast
leading up to it let's start there
so um the day of the podcast we when
they have the podcast in like this
apartment building so when we got there
um they basically told us the floor to
go up to so when we got up there you
walk in and right away like they tell
you to stay quiet like stay silent you
can't speak
and he had they had like a segment going
on
yeah it was live so they were telling us
to stay quiet and then that's when they
had us fill out like the the
um consent form like to be on camera and
um they told us to take off our shoes
they said that there's no shoes and no
vaping
because they said that if you leave they
think the fire alarm's gonna go off and
then that's not true after that yeah
yeah and um after that uh they finished
the segment and that's when walter came
over to me and my friend and then all
the girls started coming in
and they had like this i believe he was
the soundtech guy because he kept
telling us to speak into the mic but he
told us the rules so he came up to us
and he told us listen like when you go
on you have to speak into the mic you
can't interrupt minor they said that you
can disagree with him until the sun
comes up as long as you wait for your
turn and you let him speak that's what
they said
and um
they said that no shoes of course and
you can't look at yourself in the
monitor like or the chat
and then there was um they also took our
phones before we went live like they
took all of our phones in a basket so we
couldn't use our phones this guy really
thinks he they do think she's like dave
chappelle or something like
like the way they have that locked down
and stuff is pretty incredible for a
small time podcast
yeah and um
so it was so they finished the segment
and then that was the time that we all
like mingled with the girls to get to
know each other and stuff and then there
was this other guy that worked for him i
i just know that he's the one that does
the streaming before the live to show
people like um what's going on behind
the scenes and stuff and he's mostly
like the advertiser like on social media
he just controls i believe that's what
he does but he came up to me and my
friend and he offered us alcohol he said
like do you guys want a drink and i was
like no thank you because
um like you know like i've drank in high
school and stuff like that but i knew i
was going on a podcast so i knew i
wanted to be coherent when i was like
online so this is before you go on
you're 19 years old and they're offering
you alcohol that's classy
yeah and then so they they offered me a
white claw so i was like no thank you
and they were like come on so like i
just took the white call and i opened it
and pretended like you know like oh yeah
i have a white cloth pressure yeah in
fact to take an alcoholic beverage we
love that
yeah and then and then after that um the
one guy he came out with like a tequila
bottle i don't know where he got this
bottle from but he was like oh who wants
to take a shot with me and the two other
girls were like no thank you and then he
looked over at me and my friend and he
was like come on guys come on like come
on take a shot with me don't make me do
this by myself
and so my friend was like you know
whatever i'll just do it so he could
stop asking basically and um she took
the shot with him and then from there on
like they just did all the advertising
and like she's like taking pictures of
us for the thumbnail and um myron came
out and actually like he's pretty tall i
told sam this like when i was like
telling her the notes and stuff he's a
very tall person in person
but um he came out and i was like
what not expecting him to look the way
he did and walter came up to me and he
said to me um do you want to go on a
double date with me and myron
and i said with who and he said your
friend so he wanted they wanted to go on
a double date with my friend
me and fresh and fit
and they said that they wanted to vlog
it and then
invasion
um
remember you used to do that
so again you're 19 he's 35 and he's
trying to take you out on a date
so yeah um walter was the one that
approached me on it mind you i hadn't
even had i didn't say a word to myron so
i never like knew who like i didn't know
him in person i knew him from like
social media but like he never spoke to
me the whole time until we got on the
podcast
so
walter came up to me like with this
proposition of we're gonna go on a vlog
and oh like it's gonna be a big deal and
i simply was like no like i'll pass on
it simply because i don't want to be
associated with them like at all smart
so
i was like yeah i'll think about it and
then after that my room came over and he
said can you guys believe ethan klein
just did a video about us
and then that's when i i like i was
smiling because i was like i'm a fan so
i was just thinking you're like i'm
gonna end up on his show talking about
this yes
why would i was he excited or was he
like pissed no no no no well he was like
laughing but the thing with him is like
if i listen i don't have my phd or
anything but i think he's very easy to
read that he laughs over his
insecurities like it's so obvious how
like oh yeah
i'm not mad about this but he clearly is
right um
he like tries to make it he does it
several times when when women debate him
he just laughs over it but he makes
himself look ten times more stupid but
he did it like that he was like oh mike
can you believe ethan what a what a guy
he's he's talking about me blah blah
blah blah and i was smiling like on the
couch and i was next to walter and
walter was i looked over at walter and i
said so you guys going to go on the
podcast and he was like
we're going to think about it and then
that's why
and i said to walter well i actually
watched the h3 podcast so
and he was like yeah that guy yeah i
don't know they were just very like they
just switched the subject right away
so by the way i just want to note
how creepy it is
that they're trying to get you group of
girls
uh
alcoholed up when the two of them don't
drink i mean that is so messed up not
just from like
first of all they're trying to make you
guys look dumb on the show and then look
smart exactly and then he's also trying
to take you out on a date i mean the
whole thing is just weird and
inappropriate
and vlog it i guess i don't even know
why
and what
and vlog it i guess oh yeah and vlog it
because they gotta prove that we're
[ __ ] yo we get chicks bro
make sure you guys subscribe yeah but um
she oh she so after that like like they
started talking about you and the h3
podcast they're like oh yeah we're gonna
talk about it today so they added it to
their segment at the end of the show
and that's when i went on the show they
started and like the whole time i felt
like i was sweating because like the
monitor is huge like right next to you
so like i'm trying not to look into this
camera and
that they start the show
it was very painful to [ __ ] like to sit
through the whole thing because
like i knew my the whole reason why i
wanted to be on the show was because i
didn't know who they were until the day
before when i did my research and i was
like i would love to go on this podcast
and like make them look stupid in some
type of way and
so i went on the podcast and then
they did like these questions like oh um
is it okay for a guy to have a side
girl and i was like no and then he said
this they said the same thing for a girl
like can a girl have a side guy and i
said no like i think it's equal when
you're in a relationship like there's a
fascinating conversation by the way
yeah exactly
go ahead yes or no
no it was a great discussion like the
title but
um
and he um
so it was they said something at the
beginning where like they they call it a
plant where they know that so i think
they picked up on it now some girls go
on the show to like pretend that they're
interested to like debate them so over
some time i think myron picked me out of
the crowd and he was like oh you he made
a joke about the sims he said that oh i
think you played the sims because you
want to make it like an all-girl world
like basically call me a feminist
and the worst insult of course to levy
against a woman
yeah and i just laughed and i was like
yeah and okay
and then um
when i had said the whole thing about a
girl having a side guy and a guy having
a side girl i said i think that
both a man and a woman should be equal
in a relationship where you guys need to
respect each other and he basically said
so you think men and women are the same
and i said no i don't that's so funny
dude the dude is like he has one
trick he literally just tried to survive
every conversation of how men and women
are fundamentally different
and anyone that tells you that's crazy
like i i see where he's trying to lead
the conversation in a way where he's
comfortable talking about it
and he he was like i'm gonna take a note
of that we're gonna come back to this
discussion and i was like i don't think
many women are the same but when it
comes to a relationship it's it's like
you're basically one person at the end
of the day so they're the same and he
was like i disagree
and the whole like after that like the
rest of the podcast like he would find
any time that he could to like sound
bite me or like play the sound board or
like do something and then after that
like i was like over it by the end of
the show but
um at the end of the podcast they were
reading the super chat and of course all
of his
fans were coming at me the whole time
and they were saying like oh she doesn't
like biological reality meaning like you
know like i don't like the fact that men
can cheat and women can't
yeah that's a biological reality
apparently on the fret in the fresh and
fit universe it's just understood by the
men of course the women they still
haven't they still haven't got that memo
we're working on that boys yeah
yeah and then i basically just like
that's my time like i took it as my time
to shine because it was like final
thoughts and they were like oh what do
you have a rebuttal against that and i
basically said
i it's not that i don't like this
biological reality it's the fact that i
don't like that your podcast sits here
and likes to normalize this thing and he
was like oh you think we normalized
these things and i said yeah i think you
like to sit here and say that men can
cheat and women need to get over it and
he went quiet and he said well i think
women can cheat and i said at the end of
the day no one should be sitting here
talking about cheating and how it's okay
and how i have to deal with it if a man
has a rolls royce or this and that
because at the end of the day no one
gives a crap about that like i don't
care what you have all i care about is
respect and then they um
and i also had said to him to like why
do you want to feed into this stereotype
that women want money but you sit here
like
and feed into it like it just doesn't
make any sense to me but well the
double standard to me that's always
funny is like
they want a young beautiful perfect
bodied woman
right that's all they care about
they want to dumb dumb and young
and so if a woman wants you for your
money what's the [ __ ] difference
between the two
yeah it's it's but he said he said
something along that line during the
podcast where well those are my
standards and like he said but he
basically says the same thing that he
did for the australian people where he
said open am i enclosed on yours like
that's his whole mindset and it's just
embarrassing but it was just funny to
see like my experience with him
afterwards which was um
after the show ended uh they gave us a
ride home so uh we had gone into the car
and that i they closed off the podcast
talking about you they said oh well this
guy just challenged us and also by the
way they subscribe to you they they're
subscribed to the h3 podcast of course
they are and by the way that invite is
still open which they're too cowardly to
accept it's pathetic at this point
well after they said like oh yeah we're
gonna take on the challenge when they
said it on live we had gotten into the
car afterwards and it was me my friend
fresh and fit and then another girl from
the show and as we were driving um back
to the my friend's apartment they
started talking i i basically brought it
up and i was like so you guys are gonna
debate ethan and they said now we're not
going to do it like he's just going to
make fun of us the whole time and i was
like i don't think he would do that but
maybe he would never do that
yeah
no but i actually am i am genuinely
interested in having
uh discussing these issues with them
not that i think it's like i don't think
you can really get anywhere with them
but there you go you see their whole
time their whole plan from the beginning
was to dodge us
yeah they were basically saying all of
that and then um
we
we got back to the apartment and i left
my wallet and i guess it was a gift from
god but
i left my wallet in myron's car because
he was the one driving and my my
friend's keys were in my wallet so we
had to get the wallet back because we
couldn't get back into the apartment
mind you it's like 5 a.m in miami and we
start calling walter he's not answering
it's like a whole game of cat and mouse
and myron gets the wallet and walter was
like oh he wants your friend's number if
he's gonna bring back the wallet meaning
me
so
i was like
um
sure like i need my wallet like i'm not
gonna text this guy anyways
so
um he gets my number and he brings back
the wallet and i had basically texted
him saying like don't steal my wallet
like before he put it back
and then he started talking about how i
look like tim poole and i was like
sorry was he is that his way of coming
on to you
i guess i thought i don't know
that it was just he sent me i tell that
to you sometimes when i want to be
really nice when she looks really good
babe you look like tim cool he's got
such can i see a picture of you or do
you do not want me to draw attention to
it i actually i mean if i can i could
turn on the camera i just don't want to
show my face on the stream well i want
to i want to see i want to rate you on a
scale of tim pool
i think i'm pretty timpool to uh regular
you know what you know the problem is
though it's definitely i think i said i
i sent uh i think i sent a few pictures
to sam
all right let's let's pull it up
so go go go continue on with his uh tr
attempting to according you while i pull
up this yeah
so um he
he uh yeah so he said he looked like tim
poole and then i guess that was his way
of flirting i don't know and then he
tried to maintain a conversation with me
like through text and i was like
not answering him because i had gotten
my wallet back and i only had about like
three more days i i had left in my trip
and me and my friend were saying like
you know it would be fun to sit here and
like
make him look dumb like he sits here and
he thinks that he can get all these
women but then a 19 year old like
doesn't like you know like um rejects
him
so
um basically he he kept like texting me
every day like when i wouldn't respond
he would just say hello hello hello like
called me i never answered and then
eventually i was a little desperate
and then i was like you know if i'm
gonna hang out with him like i'm okay to
hang out with him to like because you
know like you can't interrupt him on the
podcast but i can interrupt you at
dinner so i basically said you know what
um yeah if we're going to hang out i
want to eat dinner or go to lunch simple
and he said well you can come to my
place and see if you can handle me
and
i was like no he said if you can handle
this and i said hold on i have a picture
of you hold on
i don't know i
i hate to break it to you but
yeah i'm pretty simple that is a
spitting image of
i don't know if you can see it is
literally a picture of temple i'm not
making fun of the way you look
i was supposed to stay anonymous why'd
you guys show a picture
yeah sorry well if you want to be
anonymous don't we don't have to pull it
up
no big deal no no no no i'm kidding yeah
it was it's just because like i'd rather
not like get wrapped into their
because you know you ca if you use
if you take one of their brooms and beat
them up with it you know it's a big deal
but
i don't know if you remember him saying
that if you go to his room shop
why oh yeah something about beating up
each other with a broom or some [ __ ]
right
yeah
i think he
the broom is interesting i think he's
tapping into some trauma
hmm
did you find a picture sam
this person
just said she's definitely trolling you
all
uh for any i should have said this at
the top we've we've confirmed that she's
been on the show
uh she was there uh this is all
she this is a real person who's been on
the show we confirmed it so i should
have said it at the top
but uh all right let me see i got a
picture
oh my god dude what the hell
should i show it or no
oh don't show it yeah
oh i thought i was supposed to show it
no
oh don't show it
you could describe it i mean all right
she's wearing a beanie she appears to be
bald
[Laughter]
yeah it's me
no she's a young beautiful she's a
young beautiful girl that looks nothing
like tim i don't see any resemblance
whatsoever so
uh but that's really interesting
you know i'm sure it's a conversation
starter
yeah he that's how he started it all but
from there he just basically just kept
texting me like every day like um
hey like and i and like he would ask to
hang out but i would make up an excuse
like oh no sorry i have to do something
today sorry i'm hanging out with my
friend that's awesome and i basically i
would hint at it like several times not
hints at it but i would say like if
we're gonna go about can izzy and walk
so
can my friend and walter come and she
and he was like oh well you can't leave
your friend alone and i was like
not really because it was because i i
never wanted to be alone with him at all
i did not want to be alone with him
and um so
the days go by and it's my last day in
miami and i thought it was gonna be my
last day but i had got stuck there
because of a snowstorm back at home
so i thought it was my last day and mia
and my friend had gone out to the club
that was like around like around her
area
and when we went in there we were we
were doing our own thing and walter had
showed up and he came up to us like we
went to his table he was talking to us
and he comes straight up to me and he
says
oh myron wants you and i said
a child
like because i i know i'm not a
i know i'm not a minor i mean you're 19.
and i'm a french i'm refreshing out of
being a minor yeah i mean you you
practically just finished high school at
that point right
yeah i i probably just finished my first
year of college but
and so was it weird for you for this 35
year old 35 year old man to be so uh
so persistently pursuing you yeah
it was very i'm what i describe it as
like when i like on the podcast i was
sick to my stomach just being on the
podcast itself
but um
like just being in his presence like
later in the night i felt very sick
because it was just weird like just like
so i find it odd too that his buddy he's
these guys are they're like
kindergartens like he's sending his body
they'd be like hey you want to go on a
double date or yo my buddy really likes
you it's like dude this guy talks about
alpha maleness he like he he's sending
love notes through his body which is
cute you know if it's age appropriate
i i think they said that there's a rule
that for a guy to date someone it's half
your age plus seven or something like 12
and i am pretty sure i'm way below that
even if that was half
seven is the one that i've heard many
times and i don't think 19 would be
acceptable under that level two or
thirty wait that's interesting so wait
i'm 36
so i go times two plus seven no divided
by two plus seven it would be twenty
five girls twenty five that seems young
for me
25
i i mean this is not a actual rule this
isn't like a lot people say yeah um uh
that's kind of just like a guideline but
yeah i mean if he's 35. wait if you're
60 wait i'm interested by this rule
so
minus two
no divided by two yeah
plus seven thirty seven if you're sixty
see that seems fine to me i mean
obviously a big gap
uh okay
yeah if it was an actual rule uh yeah he
would have failed that one but
it's pretty rough but he um
yeah i guess i said to walter like a
child like i'm
young and i said what is it so
attractive about me that he wants me
this fat that it's been like three days
that he can't get out of my cell phone
and also he talks about being this
famous number one men's podcast but
you're stuck on a 19 year number one
men's podcast what does that even mean
like
number one human trafficking podcast in
the world
it's not the competition isn't tight
yeah it's
what i had asked him like what what is
it about me that he's so attracted to he
said you're his type again i said a
child and
[Music]
he said no um
uh he said no you're just his type and i
said can you elaborate but he wouldn't
elaborate so i said to him i said i
disagree on everything that he says um i
i i'm pretty sure i look um pretty young
and i don't know what it is like about
whatever so we get to the point of my
walter just keep saying that my room
wants me wants me and i was like okay
then i'll get back to him later the
night
and i was trying to avoid him as much as
possible and then the night goes on and
um i have like a drink or two with my
friend and
i'm i'm like ready to eat food with
everybody so we tell we tell walter can
we go get food and he's like yeah sure
like let's get in the car so we get in
the car my friend is in the front seat
i'm in the back seat walter's in the
front
and they're driving and myron just kept
saying like
oh do you want to go get something to
eat i'm like yeah sure like let's go
with my friend and walter and he was
like
yeah sure sure
i also tried getting myron out to the
club so again like i didn't want to be
alone with him and he refused to go to
the club because he said clubs for
losers but it's great for girls i i
don't know what he meant by that but
um
he
so walter my friend was like oh yeah
that's great let's get food with each
other and walter looked over and like
signaled her like no like we're not
doing that
so eventually like they pull up into we
pull up in front of the podcast
apartment and myron's coming out of the
building and i get out of the car and
walter leaves with my friend and took
her
so
i'm with my room by myself so he we get
into his car and he drives us to like
this like
place this spot i don't know why it was
open at 5am but
he um
we sat down we ate food and mind you
from the minute i saw him when i got the
card to the minute that i left with him
i was debating him the whole time and
not even debating just telling him how
much i hate his views and like him
himself
and
fun fact he told me that he's never been
in a relationship so i had asked him so
what gives you the right to sit there
and have a podcast wait wait wait wait
wait he's never been a relationship
that's what he claimed he said that yeah
he's had a few girls here and there i
think he mentioned that on the episode
that i was on too but he said he's never
been in a relationship before so you're
telling me
these toxic reg pill mess this theory of
man can cheat women can't has not worked
out for him uh really at all has it
which is so unexpected yeah
by the way i don't know if you can see
my screen but
this is what you could have been like
uh if you would have only accepted a
fit into your life
you know you guys could have been a
beautiful couple like these two here
i think you're really missing out on
something special
yeah it was just so he said they got you
alone with him
yeah so basically my friend was alone
with fresh and i was alone with fit
perfect perfect night and um we get to
like this restaurant and i basically
asked him like what are your political
views i'm asking about all of his views
because i'm i'm thinking like if
walter's this nice off camera maybe
meyer is the same way nope i was wrong
um
in fact he's worse but um so he
yeah whatever the whole time i'm just
like asking him his views i'm debating
him he says something about like the
thing too that his habit is is that he
spits out vocab vomit and he thinks that
he sounds smart but it's like i'm
confused like speak like we're off
camera you can speak english now not
readable beta like no and
he just doesn't stop so like i'm just
like whatever so that's the whole
conversation throughout the dinner and
then we're driving back and i mind you i
had said like oh we're gonna go meet my
uh walter and my friend now right and he
said yeah yeah yeah i'm talking to him
i'm facing him in the driver's seat i'm
still going i'm passionate and heated
telling him my views and stuff and we
ended up back at the podcast studio
so i'm like uh
you know like i'm ready to go home and
we get back up into the podcast studio
and we go inside he's like oh i'm just
picking up something i just had to grab
something from the studio and again it's
like four or five a.m in miami and like
no one's in the studio but the lights
are all on they have everything set up
and i already have like i already knew
the way of the apartment so i'm sitting
in the kitchen area of the podcast
studio
and
he comes over to me and he says of
course you would wear your shoes because
i forgot to take off my shoes what
yeah
and
he he was like of course you would wear
your shoes
and then um i had had like this little
vape that my friend had and i think i
hit it once and he goes oh and of course
you would do that in here too
and i was like oh my i'm so sorry like i
started laughing because i thought he
was joking but he seemed very upset
so i was like okay so he said oh you can
just go to the balcony with your shoes
and everything and i was like okay i'm
walking out to the balcony and there's
like a door that i hadn't seen open
before like basically it's an apartment
that they made into a studio so that was
the bedroom so i'm walking like towards
the bedroom into the balcony like
towards the balcony and he's standing in
the door frame and he just grabs my face
and kisses me wow there you go he was
reading the room good at reading the
signal yeah
and i kisses me i i'm like no think like
you know i'm like no thanks mind you
this man is like six foot seven
did he lead with tongue or no
i i don't even like thinking about it
i'm sorry i shouldn't
right it's okay let's not relive that
moment but
he
he he had kissed me and then i like
i just was like no thanks like you know
whatever and i was also by i was by
myself with him and i had like a bad
experience from a past relationship so
also he's very like
aggressive online so i didn't know what
he was capable of if i denied it so i
just pushed him off and i was like oh
i'm just going to go to the balcony and
he goes
you need mouthwash
yeah what
you need mouthwash um i i'm pretty sure
i think i sent some texts over to sam
because i got the text here
yeah i was texting my friend the whole
time you see me say like he just told me
to get mouthwash or something let me
pull up this text again guys we have
receipts this is fully vetted bro mine
just grabbed me
to make out and he goes get your
listerine you taste like alcohol
no he obviously knows you came from the
club he's disgusting wait till i get
home is walter driving you yes i'm still
at the club though ask walter if he can
pick me up from the studio drive us both
home
i'm about to walk answer now she's all
worried about you bro oh wait yeah
please let me know are you okay i'm good
bro it's disgusting continuing
oh you want me to sleep
yeah yeah you can continue after like
because like um it's just like the
timeline because it's going to be like a
big
i'm leading up with the suspense you
know but yeah um i i come back from the
balcony because i again like i went to
the balcony and tried to stay as much as
i could out there so he could just like
be like okay like let me bring her home
now like get tired of me basically so i
come back in the room and then i go to
the bathroom like in the kitchen he's
like that's not where the mouthwash is
so i was like oh okay um where's the
mouthwash and he points to like the
bedroom bathroom are you a little scared
at this moment
i was very uncomfortable i was very like
like i again like i didn't know again
like a lot of people i didn't want to
speak out about this either because
again like there's alcohol involved you
know like a lot of women try to speak
out about stuff like this and you
usually get the whole like you asked for
it if you didn't do this or that the
third but like when i was in that moment
like i didn't it was like a fight or
flight or like freeze so i basically
froze like i didn't know what to do but
i was just like keeping in touch with my
friend like
hey like what are you guys doing like
can we just go home but yeah i mean i
was just trying to see you there at this
moment it does sound
a little scary that you're in this
studio with this massive dude
he's just come on to you he tried to
kiss you you rejected him and now he's
he's kind of ordering you around to
mouthwash because at that point it's
like well why am i mouthwashing are you
going to try to make out with me more
yeah and i don't really see the point in
doing the mouthwash of like i i don't
know so i i just go into this bathroom
that he led me to like he didn't leave
me to he just pointed to it and
also i always forget this part whenever
i tell the story but like but a little
bit beforehand i had opened the fridge
before like he kissed me and stuff i had
opened the fridge and i saw like he had
white claws like because they have like
alcohol in the fridge and stuff and they
have they had a white claw in the fridge
and i was like oh white claws like oh
can i have one like as a joke and he was
like yeah you can have one but just
don't tell anybody
well you broke that yeah
yeah sorry sorry myron but
um he so i go so fast forward i'm in
this bathroom um i'm standing in the
bathroom like trying to kill time again
on the balcony when i come out he's like
laying on this bed so wait you just you
look you were in the bathroom for a long
time just trying to kill time
yeah yeah i was just like like because
hopefully like i was hoping like time
would go by and he would get tired and
it's like oh you have to go
you know like so you were just in the
bathroom for a long time you probably
thought you were [ __ ] or something
yeah yeah i was dropping a grumpy but oh
yeah um
and
he i come back out and i was wearing
like a fresh
sorry guys excuse me but um
i i was wearing a fresh hoodie and
because
they have like a room full of merch but
i asked them where does it go they say
nowhere so they all just collectively
wear fresh and fit like all day long but
whatever so um i i'm like standing up
next to this bed and i'm texting my
friend like like because we're just
keeping in touch with each other back
and forth like what's going on and she
wanted to go home i wanted to go home
but
the moral of the story it's the guys
were texting and the girls were texting
so like i kept telling myron like i want
to go home like izzy's waiting for me
like can we go and walter said to my
friend at the club
he said um why are you texting her why
are you texting your friend to go home
like like it was basically like my room
was telling walter like why is her
friend telling her to go home like it
was just a whole what on earth dude
you're telling him you want to leave
like what the [ __ ]
is it in some remote area where you kind
of feel like stuck there without
assistance like where are you
it was it was like miami's very
city-like so like it wasn't like i was
alone but like i don't know i just
didn't know my way around anywhere so i
was just like i didn't know what i was
doing right it's not your city
yeah i didn't have the keys to my
friend's apartment so i didn't feel like
going like taking an uber there and just
waiting right so
that's when i had asked her like oh can
you have him drive to here to pick me up
and
he was refusing and it was the whole
thing and then so at this point like i'm
standing next to his bed and then um i'm
like trying to like you know again like
give him
cues like i want to leave i don't want
to be here and he's like oh you can sit
on the bed so i sit on the bed and i'm
sitting at the edge of the bed you know
like the memes how they say how girls
are and um i'm sitting at this edge then
he's like oh you know you can come up a
little bit more so now i come up and i
leave a nice gap between the both of us
where it's like very obvious like i
don't like you that i'm leaving a gap
between us
and i'm on my phone he's on his phone
and i remember again i was speaking
about my views once again he just jumps
on top of me and starts making out with
me
like like trying to kiss me and stuff
and so i'm like i have my hands like on
him where it's like i don't want him
like laying on me like intimately so i'm
just holding my hands up and i'm like no
no
this was about like
max a minute long and i was wearing like
this shirt and it's like a very loose
shirt whatever and he basically lifts up
the shirt and made a comment and then i
was like i'm done i'm over this like
wait he lifted up your shirt and kind of
looked at
underneath it and commented yeah yeah my
chest because i have i have
you i'm sorry you you say what
i said i have piercings so he made a
comment on it oh okay
and it was very creepy so i i i don't
want to uh
this
this is
a bad this is very bad
this is a very disturbing uh story
actually
it's pretty it's interesting but i
thought i think he may have assaulted
you i mean at this point i
yeah i mean i don't want to say that but
like again like
that's it's just it was like he also
implicationed you a little bit too the
way they
they bro they split you guys up and
i think you got implications i think you
got dennis systemed
if you know what that is
no
oh okay sorry
it's always funny thing okay
um so yeah no so what's going through
your what's going through your mind as
he it's lunging on you
now
it was it was very quick so i was just
like no like right away in my head i was
like no i don't want to have like sex
with this person like i don't so i like
as soon as he like makes that comment i
push him off me and i say
i i verbalized to him i said i don't
want to have sex with you did you think
i came here to have sex with you
and
he got very mad like he just got mad
like he just like he did like a little
toddler thing where he was huffing and
puffing went and goes on his phone and
he just like went silent and i was like
okay like i'm and i changed back into
the outfit that i had in the bathroom
and i came out i give him the merch back
and i say okay can you bring me home now
and because my friend was like my friend
was also like drunk at the club with um
walter and she was texting me saying
like i'm gonna walk home because he's
not bringing me home
and it was just like a whole true
gentleman neither so
both of them are refusing to give you
guys rides home
yeah and and so yeah so i i had asked my
rent i said can you drive me to my
friend's apartment and he said no i
parked my car already
so
i was like okay i'm gonna order my uber
now and he was like okay like just
acting like a complete toddler like in
my in like entire like i felt like i was
looking in the face of a 15 year old
like a 15 year old boy that like oh i
didn't give him a kiss or whatever like
but um
at that point i uh excuse me i feel like
i got the burp but
um i order my own uber
and i'm walking out and i'm like oh my
my uber's coming like can you knew
walking downstairs because i didn't know
how to work this building so he walks
into the elevator pushes the button and
walks away like with no comment he just
pushes the button and walks back into
the studio
and i get into my uber and like at that
point i think that's when it kicked in i
started crying because i was like i
don't know what just happened but i feel
uncomfortable and i i that's where you
can read the rest of the messages of my
friend because i mentioned everything in
there you started crying
uh i don't blame you that whole thing is
really traumatic and i'll tell you what
i actually didn't know how
how crazy this story gets at the end i
i'm sorry you went through that
yeah it's all right i just wanted to
bring it more i mean wow
the thing that's really crazy is like
if you're hanging out with somebody
you know you don't always have to give
someone a ride home
but what's messed up is
they intentionally split you guys up
and then he took you all the way out to
the studio
and then basically stranded you there
he's like well if you want to leave you
got to [ __ ] pay for your own ride i
mean
what the [ __ ] dude
but anyway it's a good thing he didn't
give you red home because who knows what
else
he would have tried on you
okay so let me let me read this uh he's
disgusting wait till i get home is
walter driving you home yes i'm so at
the club though ask walter if you can
pick uh me up from the studio drive us
both home
i'm about to walk out answer bro please
let me know if you're okay i'm okay dude
he's disgusting i'm making him driving
home right now are you going home
yes i'm going home soon okay i'm gonna
make him drive me home right now myron
just tried to have sex with me i said no
and he's mad because i said no
lol the [ __ ] did he expect dude when you
when are you going home he's a [ __ ]
weirdo
is walter bringing you home because i
told myron you're going home right now
so he can uber me home
i'm leaving soon
but if he knows walter is taking you
home he's going to be weird
why is he texting walter
i think so but wait leaving with walter
right leaving now yes leave now now what
are you doing one minute away i'm
getting my uber
three minutes away bro byron's a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
home
need me to come down and wait
now now now i'm getting my uber blah
blah blah yes please kay bro i want to
cry i'm coming we'll talk
i'm coming down the block
i
hate to say it i don't want to make you
feel some type of way but
that was super in that
that was that's crazy
the best part is the day after this is
the wait there's more
yeah and wait there's more and remember
just remember this is a 35 year old man
who's stranded this a 19 year old girl
in his apartment
trying to get her drunk all night
jumping on top of her and then making
her give ride get her own ride home
after he doesn't get
what he wanted from you
uh wow okay so what happened the next
day
so basically um i i sent those over too
but um
wait there's more should i open
something else screenshots of text from
my ring should i look at this yeah just
just for back story too um when i had
gotten back to my friend's apartment i
told her what had happened i was like
telling her like this is what happened
and we basically agreed i was like okay
let's go to sleep and in the morning if
i say the story the same way i did last
night then it happened because i felt
like i was imagining the whole thing so
she was like okay so we go to sleep um
we wake up the next day and we the first
thing we did when we woke up is like
this i told her the whole story again
and she was like yup everything's the
same way you said it before and then
right away i look at my phone and
there's a text from myron and then
that's where you can read those sites
okay here we go from myren
i don't know if yesterday was planned
with you
but it wasn't cool i really didn't think
you were the that type of girl oh he's
mad at you
yeah he was very mad because i didn't i
didn't give it up i i say it further in
the chat so first thing in the morning
he's texting you hate messages
i don't know if yesterday was playing
with you and your friend but it wasn't
cool i really didn't think you were that
type of girl very disappointing
type of girl what to just want to hang
out and not want to [ __ ] me the minute
you see me
so you you say what do you mean by that
type of girl and what do you think
could have been planned between us
if i can't get an explanation with that
type of girls then don't label me as
that you know what you did
actually don't so please enlighten me
you could come over and we can talk
about it how does this guy still want to
hang out
he's still trying to get you back to his
house holy [ __ ]
and during this time like i didn't want
to say it right away i'd rather him say
it for himself like you know like this
is why i'm mad and that's why you see me
like avoiding it yeah what did i do what
did i do
he just never says it
but he keeps going he says like so you
say i'll continue to say what makes you
think i would want to come over
after you saying i had possibly planned
something
then saying i know what you did
you know what you did he says all right
no
not to my apartment i was gonna meet in
the lobby and talk about it
uh did you not read what i said you also
text me in a rude way and childishly
saying you know what you did but won't
exactly explain what that meant or what
you think i'm planning and disregarding
my question as to what the type of girl
meant because i honestly want to know
exactly you can't call me anything
because you're quiet
don't project your anger onto me because
they don't have sex with you who's this
yeah he tried to play the the card oh i
don't know who this is i deleted your
number like that really pulled a heart
string on that one i cried for days wait
wait wait he said that a day later or
later that night how long yeah no
because because i i um after i had sent
those texts like the there's the two um
last bubbles you see the one before that
before you see the date um he didn't
answer me for a few days and i had
gotten home from miami and i was like
he's not responding to me so i might as
well just say my piece and then that's
it so that's when i had said what i said
like few days later
yeah
can i put a theory forward
about these text messages and tell me
what you think
because obviously this happened to you
it's happened to a lot of people i think
he preemptively texts you in the morning
and accuses you of doing something
and he won't say what it is is he trying
to give himself some kind of alibi in
case there's any allegations against him
because he know he [ __ ] up
and it will look really really really
really really bad if you told this story
so that's how i read this is he's like
i'm going to send this message
saying you did something and i'm not
going to say what it is
so that if there's ever her trying to
expose me i have these texts that
apparently you did something and i
didn't do anything
yeah i mean i don't know what else would
it what do you think he's trying to do
with this with these texts i i think he
was just like
i don't know i i i agree but i also like
felt like
i think he i think he really believes
himself like i'm some type of girl like
how how dare you not want to have sex
with me i'm sure it could have been
genuine i have i have all these cars and
all this money and how dare you like i
didn't know you were that type of girl
to have respect for yourself i think
that's right right
right i'm so disappointed
yeah i'm so disappointed that our lab
elaborate plan to separate you two and
sleep with you both after meeting you
once i'm so disgusted by you
yeah
that's exactly what i felt like because
i really think he lives in a world
like i think he believes everything he
says like i i do believe he's insecure
but everything that he says i think he
genuinely believes well he's never had a
girlfriend and he's and he's
yeah he said something too along the
lines like on on the episode i was on he
said that he never chased after girls in
high school in school because it was um
it was a distraction and my another
friend of mine said just say you didn't
get girls it's simple say that but
what's weird is like if he wasn't such a
creepy
brain rotted weirdo like he's tall and
he's fit
in the name
you would think that if you just would
lighten up a little bit and be like a
reasonable normal guy you would know no
trouble he had no problem attracting
women and getting into a relationship
but
there's something out with a 19 year old
i mean oh sure yeah i mean
but there's something so disturbed about
him and did you i don't know if you're
watching before but he was a he was a
federal agent for human trafficking what
the [ __ ] dude yes
my friend lives across the street from
uh like a prison and when he had dropped
off my wallet he was like oh i was
stationed here once or so he said
something like that and that's when i
found out that he used to be a law
enforcement officer
for human trafficking department
yeah
yeah he he takes one to no one i guess
yeah
that's how he caught them knew where
they were
wow well this took
an unexpected dark turn
you know i i i basically when i spoke
the same also sam she's amazing she's
very sweet wait who's sam
oh my god what is wrong
wait hold on i need a minute i need a
minute to recover
give me a minute if you need to
i thought she was talking about her
friend
i was confused i thought she was talking
about
the other friend there
she kept referring to sam and i don't
know why my brain
sam i know who you are
i appreciate everything you do
i know your name
i need i need a minute to recover
guys it is wednesday
it is wednesday
it is wednesday my dudes that's true
oh are you really the apology podium dan
shredder is opposed
all right
give me one sec i just need to make a
quick apology if you don't mind hanging
on for a second
[Music]
sam
you are loved you are appreciated
you are seen
i'm well aware of your name
congratulations on the weight loss by
the way i'm really proud of you i'm
jealous actually
um
you're talented
funny
your name is sam
it is i know exactly who you are
i was confused
i thought maybe she was talking about
her friend sam and that her maybe her
friend's name was sam it was me i was
trying to connect the dots
it was actually sam here in the
on the crew so i apologize
and uh it'll never happen again okay
thank you
[Applause]
keep this closer okay
i'm sure we'll need that again soon
thank you dad
so um
well i'm not surprised but uh
some i'm not surprised by your story as
horrific as it is
but wow what a piece of [ __ ]
yeah i i was telling i had to see him um
because i the way that it happened was
that again i was watching the videos
like it was crazy because the day of the
episode i was on it was your first like
episode talking about fresh and fit and
i was like there's no way i was like
there's no way that my favorite podcast
is talking about the podcast i'm about
to be on right now and then from then on
i've just been like i watch the videos
every day but um i would like watch the
highlights of fresh and fit and i was
like you would ask questions and i would
scream at my screen like i knew the
answer and i just i just got fed up and
i just dm'd everyone and sam got back to
me and yeah i just like i needed to
speak out about this because i think
you're the best podcast to speak out
about it
thank you thank you
well thanks for sharing that story i
actually think it's really valuable and
a really good story and i think it's
brave of you to share it
i'm sorry you went through that
really scary and kind of horrific
you know it's times
as a man you don't really understand
sometimes how
how hard what was that zack
did you say something no
what you took off your headphones and
went black
sam was asking me something oh okay
you you responded really loud or
something apologies
that's totally fine you want the podium
or no no not we're podium were they i'll
let it slide
[Music]
um
i think it's really brave and it's a
reminder that
you know a simple going out as a woman
can become really scary and it's not
something that men generally think about
it's not i mean maybe some do but it's
easy to forget just how how weird it can
be out there as a woman
as a young woman
and
well
i guess stay safe what's your advice i
mean how do you avoid these kinds of
situations
i mean you never know it could be you
never know you know it's hard to live
your life and
you know i i feel like i because i a lot
of people um that i spoke to about the
story they told me they're like well if
you knew how he was like on the podcast
and like why would you
go on it or like why would you hang out
with them one-on-one the thing is like
it's so
uh like things are just so unexpected
and like the best thing you can do i i i
just i'm just glad that i got made it
out safe so like yeah i'm a very i'm a
very big believer in god so like i think
praying like not everyone's like
religious but like that's what i do but
i think it's really good to like speak
out of course due to like that's why i
wanted to bring awareness to it's like
people know that like you can you can
share the story and like you're not
like you know you're heard like people
hear you
so
look it doesn't matter you didn't
deserve for all that to happen and
to be honest like you said he could have
ended up being like a sweet guy like i
guess you you never know in a way but
yeah i guess the space sometimes uh
a spade is a spade or
yeah yeah i mean i mean he might just be
doing meth attacking i don't know but
every single deep deep deep method
acting
yeah
but thank you guys so much for letting
me share let us know if they i don't
know what's gonna be if there's gonna be
a blow back from this but let us know if
he starts
trying to [ __ ] with you okay you stay in
touch with us all right thanks for
sharing your story thank you so much of
peace and love always too
it's his fault it's not your fault
you're great you're smart
go have a great uh and a very good
storyteller i must great storyteller
yeah thank you thank you very very great
and uh go out there and find yourself
a man who uh
well coconuts and barbados yeah find
yourself some coconuts and barbados
exactly i kind of said it better myself
all right i hope you guys have a great
day thank you so much for having me
thank you peace and love peace and love
this is a serious message
i didn't know that that story was gonna
get so intense
but these red pill guys are dangerous
they're not these guys are dang like i
thought fresh and fit i was like
compared to cobra the human trafficker
these guys seem like uh
you know
just goofy harm like barney the dinosaur
or something yeah but uh no they're
actually dangerous too i mean how do you
live i don't understand the philosophy
like it's so self-defeating
the man is 35 years old he has never
been in a relationship
i mean that's just sad it's just sad
i think you know a lot of
guys like him get stuck in sort of this
self-perpetuating cycle um where you
know they become more and more bitter
because they they have no success with
women
and
rather than
examine that in an honest way
uh they just get mad and you know
concoct these
elaborate
narratives of
the way the world works and how women
really are
and everything um to sort of shield
their own egos from the fact that
they're
shitty they're yeah i mean that is
really his own fault i mean it's his own
shortcomings like you said i mean i'm
not saying the guy
is uh because i think once we mentioned
we were like oh he's a decent looking
guy and everybody's like no he's [ __ ]
disgusting but
you know i think he said he's tall
he's tall he's super he can be in shape
apparently he has money yeah
so like in his world he's like that's
all you need i have everything
i've got did the equation but why women
still don't want me it's because you're
[ __ ] suck bro right you suck
you suck that bad that you have all
those things and women still don't want
you isn't that crazy yeah
that you're i mean i didn't want to i
don't
it sounded to me like he
assaulted her
yeah
unquestionably basically that's what it
sounded like to me this is the first
time we've heard this story about him
but i'm i'm gonna bet right now it's not
gonna be the last two yeah i'm sure sure
there's a good chance if that's kind of
and the way that
and these guys
i mean this is a 19 year old girl what
are you guys doing taking them out and
separating them and getting them drunk
and you're not drinking i mean guys
what the [ __ ] are you doing
my god
yeah so i don't know these red bull guys
are not
they're not just harmlessly talking
about
dating advice these guys are [ __ ]
dangerous actually
fresh and fit the human trafficker i
don't know what role of tony brown
town's up to but
yeah we don't know enough about roller
tony i'm not going to tell you about
anything but apparently he's a family
man
he's got a daughter's [ __ ] so shout out
rola tony
what are you afraid of man
i am in better shape than you are ethan
oh
yeah better to human traffic you
he's like bro you're so weak you
probably couldn't even restrain a girl
against her will
i was like that's true actually
and the red pill community fitness is
important in case you need to uh
restrain a woman
that's why we like to be fit
i was like okay
yeah that's that's actually
i did not expect that twist but that is
disturbing man
holy [ __ ] what a [ __ ] loser and
dangerous i mean she kept saying that uh
fresh was
a nice guy
and he may well be
but he participated in that whole scheme
to separate them and not give them ride
home why are you trying so hard to have
sex
there's got to be more to life
then debasing yourself
to trying to trick a 19 year old that's
sleeping with you
there's got to be like more honorable
ways of getting sex to like
go meet someone
that actually likes you and then you can
have an arrangement with someone a
mutual you don't have to trick people
and having sex with you like i mean what
the [ __ ] dude
daniel says i'm 36 i've never had a
girlfriend i'm not red pilled just
really unlucky don't tour us shout out
daniel
there's 36 year old
virgin
shout out to uh dan
we stan you we support you
you find the one don't worry about why
don't you reach out to us i'm curious i
want to talk to you 36 year old never
had a girlfriend that's interesting to
me daniel
why don't you reach out
i listen i'm not saying
you're a creep i'm saying he's 35.
the thing is he's never had a girlfriend
his whole thing is about he's this alpha
chick magnet so
yeah i doubt that's your whole persona
it's ironic coming from him he probably
rationalizes it in his mind that it's
like oh well
you know
i don't need a girlfriend i just sleep
around and you know
i've got lots of women on call i don't
need a girlfriend
um i have relationships with women yeah
uh jordan said when the caller was
describing her situation i almost had a
panic attack because i've been in
similar situations many times not all
men but some
yeah it's scary i'm actually
it's a rude awakening that
it's not easy being a woman
it can be scary
i'm sure
i'm sure most women have or many women
have
very similar
stories people are saying daniel for the
new bachelor
let's go let's go
let's go
everyone's praying for you daniel we got
the whole chat let's go
we're praying baby get in there
come on daniel daniel daniel come on
everybody
daniel daniel daniel
[Laughter]
hey dan that's not bad huh i wonder if
people are going to talk about this
it's pretty uh
it's a lot i wonder if
he's definitely not gonna be happy about
that
i'm afraid he's gonna try to [ __ ] with
that girl so i hope she
stay stay in touch with her sam so i
don't want them to [ __ ] with her
we gotta make sure that she's okay
my throat is so [ __ ] up you guys i
gotta i gotta sign off now
ah i gotta stop doing that
so hard to do this show
sometimes it [ __ ] up my flow too like
i'm trying to finish a thought and have
a conversation and i
i can't stop doing it it's just oh
god
i rarely have ticks that are this
debilitating or painful
um
but
i'll be alright
well that was [ __ ] interesting okay
well there you go that's the show today
thank you to our caller
thank you to our watchers
today is wednesday which means tomorrow
morning
it is wednesday tomorrow morning
at 10 a.m
we are going live it's the leftovers
podcast
[Music]
it's true also 10 a.m at the same time
teddy fresh
new collection is dropping
and then friday
tick tock lawyer
oh let's go
let's go
looking forward to that
oh waking up early so tough man
that will be okay
all righty and then we should say one
more time
for anybody that missed the discussion
at the top of the show right
saturday
abey's fight is going down we're doing a
watch party stream for members it'll be
a members only stream
with the gang we're gonna got some pizza
we're gonna get some drinks we're going
to hang out it'll be a really goofy
goosey kind of time but you know we can
all watch ab
hopefully win his fight he's going to
destroy someone said they're live right
now hold on hold on
addressing the drama
what's that someone said in the comments
that they're live right now addressing
what we just talked about
let's see
that'd be surprising to me if a little
bit of box to get that and then bam then
then they're out the door which you know
i get it it is what it is if y'all want
to play that game but my thing is you
know me and fresh are really big on like
uh retention and deal with girls
that you
how do i say that they have a genuine
sense of genuine burning desire bro yeah
because if you're just sitting on this
on this transactional type [ __ ]
i don't know i'll have to check it later
i can't do that i heard a lot of people
saying that they were talking like
not about those but they're we're just
talking about random [ __ ] maybe they
have some other drama going on um
you saw some people saying for the watch
stream do you need to get anything else
besides a membership well yeah uh you
would need to get a ticket to the stream
i mean you could watch us we'll talk
about it
if you don't care in the fight if you
don't care about the fight you can watch
us talk about it
i don't know how interesting that will
be right
but yeah you will need to obtain your
own ability to watch the fight it's just
a matter of um you know watching along
with not just us but you know the chat
will be there and uh you know be
watching with the whole crowd h3 fans
it'll be fun
i'm excited man
there you go
i want to see nothing but hype up for a
b and read it and everything i saw a lot
of negative stuff when the fight what
it's all hype
maybe
well i mean i saw a lot of people saying
rap av and stuff but i want i want
people to say a b is going to destroy
you know
a little bit at the beginning but the
more that i've seen
how seriously he's been taking it and
after speaking both to his diet and
ian's coach about how these things go
and they made a lot of really good
points and like looks can be just
because honda
you know looks like a muscly dude that
doesn't mean he's the better boxer if
he's got a really good shot and yeah i
mean abe's diet regime is insane so i'm
going to call her right now i say he
knocks him out abe is going to knock him
out
really knockout i'm calling her right
now i will bet my money on it he's going
to knock him the [ __ ] out i 100
you know at the beginning when this
started cam you're right
there's a lot of memes and stuff ali has
put in the work we are fully in support
of a b he's going in there to kill
and there's a small chance that honda
might die
that's it yeah i hope that's that's he's
going to [ __ ] honda is going to lose
some teeth i i wish seriously i really
wish that honda would talk more [ __ ]
because then we could all let loose yeah
exactly he's too nice
to be such a good guy it's kind of a
classy event in that way like everyone's
being really respectful and nice which
is kind of it's kind of nice to be
honest but shout out to him may the best
man win oh i will say that no maybe come
on which is a b yeah may the best man or
a b win
no we're all a b all the way i'm super
excited
you know we're rooting for you a b good
in there come on saturday
you're
gonna be sick we're going to get drunk
we're going to eat pizza it sounds like
the best day ever we got a babysitter
ela's coming i'm [ __ ] stoked let's go
let's go
let's [ __ ] go dude
you're going to get some kebab pizza
love oh [ __ ] it
oh let's what time was it again 3 00 pm
pst we're gonna start our stream and
that's when the event that's when the
events begins as well [ __ ] that's to be
like a
that's bad for you a.m let's go
oh that's true well if you end up
passing out it's all good but it's going
to be a long event yeah
also i've been made aware that
eurovision is that night too so i'll be
oh
that's a big deal over there for you
guys huh
yeah like normal people like that [ __ ]
but i i i couldn't be bothered i've seen
i've seen it for like
18 years straight but when i turned 18
i i took
i stopped i i couldn't be forced into it
anymore gotcha all right i gotta sign
off
so thank you to all members we'll see
you on saturday but we'll see on
tomorrow before that
oh eli just responded he sounds more
like a chick repellent
i assume she's talking about
about fit fit for sure yeah i think she
hopes she's not talking maybe
i think ela's
watching a little bit uh she's probably
a little behind yeah yeah
i i'm coming home i'll see you in a
little bit
all right love you guys see you tomorrow
morning see you friday see you saturday
it's all happening
here
h3 podcast
forever
[Music]
see your partners
[Music]
you